I'm not lying because I thought we were setting things up.
Because Monopoly is one of the most unoptimized games because it's Ubisoft.
Anyway, Ubisoft, if you want to sponsor me, I won't chit-talk Monopoly.
Anyway...
Yes, I am.
But like, Monopoly Plus is known to be the most fucked up optimization.
Because this online server fucking sucks.
So I thought we were setting it up before stream.
Because I don't know how this is going to work.
Credit.
Back me up.
Is she a professional?
One time she streamed for me.
I was like, I'm going to stream from a closet.
That's true!
And I came out!
Again!
See?
What?
I don't think being proud about streaming in the closet is a good thing.
No, it is.
It is.
It's a Harry Potter origin story.
Voldemort came out of my room and he ripped off my nose and I said, wow, you sure need that, buddy.
And then he cursed me and put a scar on my head.
And to this day, I've never been the same.
Oh.
Okay, I need somebody else to back me up.
To back me up on this.
To like, rein in a Fillion.
Do we have to make a point out of me?
What is it?
A murder scene?
Okay.
All right.
Okay, Fillion.
Host the game, Fillion!
I want to talk first!
We have things to go over!
We have to figure this out and talk at the same time because at this rate, the whole thing about the game is going to take like one hour of fucking...
I want to apologize.
Tech support.
Let me just apologize to you.
Okay.
Okay, so I said a word that I would say and I wanted to tell you, I completely take it back.
That's it.
That's all I wanted to say.
Wait, what?
There was a soft drink that's really popular and I want to apologize for even mentioning it.
I just want to take it back and I'm sorry.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Thank you.
I don't know the lore.
The lore is too deep.
I got to fucking yell that, bro.
Shoot.
Fillion?
What?
No, okay.
Okay!
Okay, I'll try and start the game.
What the?
Okay.
Do you want...
Never mind.
Okay, fine.
I'll start the game, dude.
God dang it.
Yeah, I just see you on your Twitch stats right now.
I don't see the Monopoly game at all.
Why are you on Twitch?
Stop stalking me!
What do you mean?
It's because we were like, where is Fillion?
And she's out here be like, the collab starts at three.
I don't know why these girls are here early.
What is she doing?
What are they doing?
And then like, me, Lumi, and Pippa were just like, what the fuck?
And then I have to copy and paste literally a chat message from Fillion and be like, hey, how does like 2.30 sound?
And Aurel's just like, yeah, 2.30 sounds great.
I think it's our fault that we came at 2.30.
What's wrong with you?
Give me a deeper voice.
Alright?
I'm powerful.
He's like, what are these girls doing coming here like 30 minutes early?
What the fuck's wrong with them?
Okay, okay, okay.
What the fuck is wrong with her?
Dude, the last time someone came early, I got conceived.
Okay?
I'm just not used to it.
I'm starting the game.
Okay, so I want to leave my lobby code.
That's the important thing, right?
I don't think there is a lobby code.
I think it's just invite.
It's a private lobby with a code.
I don't know.
I just looked at the hosting.
I know a parent, Pipa, can't host.
Because she has issues.
I mean, not that type of issues, but like...
My net.
What do you mean by that, Doki?
What do you mean?
I'm just trying to be specific so people be like, what kind of issues does she have?
I'm like, no, I meant tech issues.
I don't mean it.
I don't mean anything else.
I think I should be able to host too, maybe?
What am I leaking?
What?
Okay.
Remote play together.
Are we actually doing remote play?
Are we going straight for the remote?
I don't know.
Someone put a thing in there.
What do you think?
Do we do it now?
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
That's what I said yesterday!
I said this yesterday!
I'm learning!
I was like, don't worry, we can do it online!
And now you're reading this?
I was like, hey guys, people in my chat yesterday were talking about we should do the remote play.
I'm all monopoly right now, Kitten.
Give me one sec.
Okay.
One person buys the game, the person who bought the game launches it and sends a request for a remote play.
So we should all be Steam friends.
Okay.
Yeah, I invited...
I added everybody on Steam.
W's in the chat.
Okay.
So I play Monopoly?
Do I go local mode?
Well, what did that person say?
It says remote.
Well, I guess it has to be local mode if it's remote play.
Yeah, create a local game, not online.
Exactly.
You're so right.
We don't want to try the online at all.
Oh no, we're just going to crash later on.
Because like, most likely...
Like when you crash, they sell off all your property and stuff to everybody else.
What?!
Yeah, so like...
Then we just have to not buy it from the AI.
It's fine.
Just don't leave my junk to the AI.
Okay, so how do I invite you guys to Steam?
There should be a remote play together button.
Oooh.
Like in the actual game?
In the Steam friends list.
Oh, in the Steam friends list.
Okay, perfect.
Don't worry, I'll go online just for you guys.
Yes, please, please, please.
So...
Okay.
So I don't know if I'm friends with Doki.
That's important.
Wait, do we not do a game?
Oh, we didn't do a game.
Yeah, we played VRChat.
It was really different.
Or wait, no, we didn't play VRChat.
You were just there.
I was just there.
Like, you just showed up.
I was like, hey, I'm filling.
I was like, yeah.
I'm filling.
So do I draw my friend code in the chat?
Is that the play?
I put my friend code already.
You scroll up.
Okay.
Did you know that someone's friend code is actually just a portion of their actual account ID?
Which means you can find it even if you're not.
Oh, we post it too.
Oh, that's cool.
Just in case.
Okay.
I will add you as a friend.
How do I...
I can't click anything because so many people added me.
I shouldn't have done that.
We should just add you.
No, I got this.
Okay.
Okay, maybe not.
Ah!
My Steam is not going to the friends...
Okay.
Maybe we should add you.
So we have an issue.
My Steam is not letting me go to my friends section.
Just refresh it.
How do you refresh Steam?
Bro, just...
Bro, just give us your friend code.
It's easier.
I don't know how to give you my friend code if I can't even go to the friends section.
Oh, you can't either.
Yeah.
Okay.
F5 is not working, Your Honor.
Do I hit Alt F5?
Oh no.
No.
F5?
Hit the button.
You can do it.
I pressed it!
Ah!
Fuck!
View friends list?
That works.
Add a friend.
Oh, okay.
Dude, I'm stuck.
Like a bug.
How are you stuck?
Okay.
Wait, can I get to my friends list from my...
Friends.
Oh, wait, wait.
I'm on the way, I think.
I'm on my friends list a different way.
So, that's pretty easy, I think.
I can just go to...
You can just go in the top and hit add a friend too.
Oh, wait.
Yeah, that's what I'm trying to do.
But the thing is, like, if I press the button, it doesn't change my Steam.
It's letting me go anywhere, but the actual place we need to go.
I know.
I'm so sorry.
How is this possible?!
Use the browser!
Go to the browser!
Oh, yeah, the sign on my browser now!
You can look at your friend code in browser!
Just go and dox it.
Okay, so can I look at my...
So how do I...
Can I copy my profile and then you guys can dox my friend code?
Wait, what?
None of us is showing our Steam!
What do you mean, Fillion?!
Okay, do I restart Steam?!
Just...
Why don't you just go on the browser?
Okay, okay, I'm walking on my browser.
Okay, okay.
Fine!
Jeez, okay, fine.
Steam login.
Alright.
Okay.
I can imagine Pippa just muting and flaming me right now, dude.
I'm not muted!
Are you flaming me though?
Want me to flame you openly?
Flaming me just flam- I'm a little more comfortable.
I'm having anxiety heavy breathing.
Just do some insults.
Okay, I signed in.
Oh, I can probably just add friends from here.
Isn't that crazy?
Yeah, I thought that.
Yeah, I remember when I said that.
Like, why don't you just turn on the browser?
No, that'd be crazy.
Okay, so I went to fr- It's telling me to sign- What?
Okay.
Okay, wait.
So how do I- Fillion has to sign in to add friends.
Come on.
Okay, okay, no, but like, okay.
So I'm on the browser, right?
Okay, I'm on the browser, right?
Okay.
There is no panel that says friends.
You can look at your Steam code.
How?
How about I host it?
Okay, fine, you host it.
Whatever, man.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, this is good.
Can I open a custom game or create a game?
Just create a game.
Local, go to local, create a game.
And then...
I'm getting replaced.
I won television.
Freaking me out.
Local?
I don't have the- You can't call me out.
I made this business.
You just get public and private.
Private, private, private.
Just do private.
Okay, private.
Living board?
Classic board?
Do living, do living, do living, do living.
Do living.
Wait, you don't have a third option?
No.
I have a third option.
We can have rapid mode.
What the fuck?
The game session will automatically start in five minutes?
Yeah, yeah, no, it does that.
Yeah, I saw that too.
Okay, let me in!
Wait, wait, wait, we should do- How the fuck do I invite?
Wait, if I host it, I have the rapid board.
Oh, I have to add you to Ubisoft.
That's what I'm saying!
No, no, no, we don't have to.
We're doing remote play.
I'm an epic failure.
Guys, this is exactly why I was like, this is going to be a lot of technical issues.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
None of you guys believe me.
I was cooking.
None of you believed me when I said- I invited.
I trusted.
None of you.
Why did you trust Fillion over me?
I am trustworthy!
Watch out!
Trust Fillion over me!
Okay, okay, I had you as a friend.
Guess what?
I got there.
Hippo, get online!
They said it could have been done, but I didn't.
That is like the lowest benchmark you can have!
Yeah, but I won the board, baby!
That's just like passing!
It's like getting a 50% and being happy about it.
I agree!
You're going to be effing single, frick you!
Alright, so now I'm here.
I invited- I'm in the remote play.
I invited everyone, I think.
You invited me?
You have to make sure you make another slot for us.
Because we're remote play.
So we need another slot.
How the fuck do I do that?
I don't know, but I'm controlling your mouse right now.
I can't click on any of these things.
You literally can't click on shit.
I'm in.
I don't know.
You literally can't click on shit!
Pull up the instructions, Fillion!
Pull up the remote play instructions!
Wait, me?
Okay!
Yes, you get the instructions!
I got this, I got this, I got this.
Don't worry, don't worry, kiddies.
The present that they've put together, friends want to play.
Make sure the host enables the keyboard and mouse controls to the friend.
Oh, okay, okay.
Enables the keyboard and mouse controls to the friend.
Enable me!
One person has to use the controller.
I'll plug in the controller.
Okay, okay, I'll use the keyboard because I'm an effing keyboard warrior.
Okay, I gave you all stuff, but...
Pitbull, your internet's not working?
Now how do I add more people?
How do you add more people?
How do I add more people?
The game's gonna start a token!
Look at the instructions.
Where are the instructions?
The instructions!
Why don't we just play on one?
Instructions, Fillion!
Okay, it says, make sure the host enables the keyboard.
and mouse controls to the friends.
That's what it says.
I gave it!
And then what?
That's what the mask is!
Uh...
That's something that says invite player.
Maybe just like, re-invite us?
No, we're all in though.
No, I can only invite through Ubisoft.
Oh, wait, what the fuck?
Oh, someone hit a B button!
Because it's me.
Wait, don't you have to?
That's me!
I brought my controller out!
Wait, are you?
I think you're in online.
You're in online, you're not local.
Go back, go back.
We are so brain damaged.
Yes, you're in online mode!
Chat, are we stupid?
What is in the comments section?
Back out again!
Local!
So how many VTubers did they just screw to life bomb?
It takes one!
Because I can basically...
I think the more VTubers you have, the longer it takes.
You have enough for Rabbids!
Bro, we should do Rabbids mode!
Do Rabbids mode!
Do it for Pippa!
Bro, we should do Rabbids mode!
What?
Is that Rabbids?
Is that Rabbids mode?
Now can you join?
I picked Rabbids mode.
This is local, right?
Did you enable keyboard for us?
Yeah, did you enable?
Can you enable us?
I fucking enabled you!
I'm taking it away from you right now!
I see your result too.
Give me my rights!
I gave you your rights.
You don't deserve any.
Thank you.
Mods!
Okay.
So how do we...
So your guy who gave you your instructions, how do we make a new person?
He just says...
Oh my god!
Okay, okay.
And then...
Lumi, add two more!
One of them has to be controller!
Okay, we got this.
How do we swap the controller?
One of them has to be on controller.
Pick something!
That's not me!
Wait, am I controlling this?
Oh, this is me!
I'm player three!
Who is me?
You have replaced nerd.
Wait, is Pippa in here?
You gotta select your thing.
You turned me into an AI!
You epic NPC-ified me!
Wait, how do we change?
Put it back!
Well, the AI will do more work than the original, so I...
No, that's not true!
I'm wearing weapon world of worship.
The AI will definitely win the game.
Okay.
Lumi, you're the top hat.
Is anyone getting game sound from this?
Because I'm not.
I have game sound.
I don't hear anything in the game.
I don't hear game sound either.
Yeah.
Is that me?
Does your guy know how to fix game sound?
What the fuck?
Pippa!
Pippa's literally an Emgrist Screamshot.
Pippa disconnected!
It's my name!
Motherfucker!
Oh my god!
Stop moving my mouth!
I'm gonna rip someone's hair out.
It could be mine.
I don't know.
Wait, you guys can hear it?
I can't hear the game sound?
I invited you.
We're all remoting.
All remote.
Okay.
How do we make this not an AI?
Okay, okay.
It's not an AI.
Pick a thingy.
Chad, can you hear the music?
No, I don't.
My chat was like, I hear it.
It's just really faint.
Can you hear music?
I barely hear it.
I don't hear anything.
You don't hear anything?
I can hear the game.
It's just really quiet.
You guys can?
It's really quiet.
Do you want me to turn it up?
Oh my god, it is!
Stop disconnecting!
Oh my god.
I hear it.
I have to turn up my volume.
Pema!
Pema, you closed the game!
What?
Join again.
Close the game!
Okay, wait.
We're still four players.
Someone get the four player in here.
I think Peppa's connection is literally dropping so often she can't even join.
Okay, player three is gonna be Pema.
And then we're gonna put player four as Doggy.
That's me?
No, no.
Doggy is a dog, right?
Doggy, did you pick the dog?
No, did I?
Maybe I did.
Okay, just pick something.
No, that's not me.
I think that's Pippa.
I think I'm player two.
Okay, okay, okay.
I accidentally picked a dog.
Okay, are we good?
Sure.
Wait, but how come there's no color next to player four?
Why are they grey?
Double do, double die.
Because, like, it's just how colors work.
Okay, fine.
It's just...
Okay.
Are we all good now?
You might need to turn up the volume.
Blast it.
I can't adjust it without exiting the menu again.
We got it.
You can't just tab out?
We got the basic necessity.
I got it.
You can't tab out, Lumi?
Holy shit.
Tabbing out?
If I tab out, it'll break the game for you guys.
Wait, there's only three players.
Fuck, fuck, fuck.
What happened to our foreplay?
It's because it was grey now.
I didn't have a color sign to it.
I redo, I redo.
Enter.
It's okay.
Why don't we just do online?
Because online's gonna crash.
Pippa!
I swear to god it wasn't gonna be that bad.
Pippa just merely existed and I blamed her.
Local creator.
Oh my god.
It's just an easier name to like and how it is.
I don't play cards against humanity.
No.
Motherfucker, I hate this shit.
We're playing Monopoly.
Can I not throw this game away?
Like it just has to be this game forever?
WHAT?
Okay, how about like Pippa teams up with somebody.
I can do it.
He's created new games.
No, not the living board.
Monopoly Rabbids.
Rabbids.
Okay.
Those are like Rabbids to Rabbids.
Those are like F tier.
Those are like Oompa Loompas, but stupider.
Rapids.
Rabbids and then Pippa.
And then Fillion can beat.
Wait, why is it AI again?
Yeah, I'm just gonna make Fillion uh... this thing.
I think that's funny.
Yeah, make me brown.
Cool, that's fine.
I'm a Poop-smasher.
Okay, I'm ready.
We start the game.
We fucking did it.
Clap it up chat!
It only took like 80 years.
Okay, we need...
There's no player 5.
All we need is Lumi to raise the volume of the game.
And then we should be set.
Lumi, please kiddin'.
Tap out and raise the volume of the video game.
Why is it at 3?
Cause it's fucking loud on my end.
Yeah, but you can turn it down on your...
Fine, fine, fine.
Where is my sound mixer?
Sound mixer...
Oh my god!
I don't know how to get it.
Harts and Chapros, guys.
Okay, okay, it's coming.
Okay, okay, I got it.
It says... the game is...
Oh, fuck.
We already know the smell of the game.
Is this loud enough for you?
Why is Lumi so quiet now?
What about SFX?
What the fuck, Lumi?
Why is Lumi quiet?
Why are you so quiet?
Did you turn yourself down, Lumi?
What is this human doing?
What do you mean?
You accidentally turned yourself down instead of the rest of the game.
Lumi, you sound like I said this is Sparta and then I kicked you down an effing hole.
You already did that in...
Whatever, shit.
Sorry, I don't take notes from like midgets, okay?
Like, actually speak up, pipsqueak.
How tall are you, bitch?
How tall are you right now?
You sound like R2-D2 on a good day.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, at least I have a brain unlike you.
You know what's funny is that I can barely hear Lumi's insults back.
Me too.
I feel like I'm listening to alien signals from Mars.
It's like hearing somebody fight back like 200 miles away.
I know.
I'm playing Ender's game and she's the alien.
She's like on the moon just shouting back at you.
All right, Lance Armstrong, chill out, bro.
We know you faked it.
Can we just do this?
Bro, you know you're so quiet.
Your volume is still low, nerd.
You're like 50% of what your original volume was.
Chill out, Chad.
No, Philly, this is 100% your fault.
Can we just go with this?
I was like, hey guys, maybe we should test this out before we stream.
Can we just go like this?
Is it good?
Is it better now?
Nobody believed me.
I undid what I did.
I undid it.
No, you're still like 50% quieter.
I don't know what you did, but you...
Just turn up on Discord now.
We'll just have to fix it.
I literally turned it up to where it was.
Okay, she's good.
Her volume is low.
I literally turned it up to where it was.
This is bullshit.
Okay, we're good.
Fuck this.
Resume.
Alright, there you go.
Let's go.
It's your turn.
Shake the dice.
Roll the dice.
Yeah.
Am I the dog?
I think so.
No, I am not.
It's somebody else.
You can do whatever you want to be.
This is remote play and everyone's playing on one computer.
Okay, I can do it.
Never mind.
You're the dog.
I'm the dog.
You're the king.
I got five.
My controller buzzes every time.
Who's rabid?
I'm the bear.
Pippa's the rabid.
Pippa, be the rabid.
I'm the pooky bear.
Okay.
I'm ending my stream because my connection is dying.
Oh, shit.
Did you roll the die for yourself or did somebody else do it?
I didn't roll it.
It wasn't me.
It wasn't Tantrum.
Now it's my turn.
You rolled a nine.
Why are you getting so defensive?
Shut the fuck up.
It's not my problem.
Don't crush your doggy.
Why me?
Six.
Number one.
I'm last.
Alright.
We're going.
Nice.
We're the winners.
First is the worst.
Second is the best.
And third is the golden bird.
Then what am I?
I'm fourth.
You're in the cock chair.
Oh.
Joy, we made it really comfy for you.
Alright.
Here we go.
Roll the dice.
Who's there?
It's Pippa.
Roll the dice.
I'm nothing bad.
Wait.
What happened to Pippa?
Are we rolling four?
Alright.
I'm playing the fucking game.
Say no.
Okay.
Wait.
Who's Who's playing this right now?
Is Pippa playing?
That's Pippa.
Touch the buttons.
Okay.
We're going to auction.
What?
Sabotage.
Ladies.
Pippa.
Why did you do that?
Why did you?
Click auction, Pippa.
I hate you.
Why did you click auction?
That's what it started with.
Yes.
Help.
Hello.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Today we're going to figure out how difficult is Monopoly really.
And we're going to beat the golden bird.
What do you think about Monopoly so far?
I think it's pretty fun so far.
I'm enjoying it.
Especially on remote.
It seems pretty fun.
She logs in easily as she breathes.
Alright.
Luffy, how are you feeling?
This is shit.
This is fucking terrible.
You all get chill in my mouth.
Just hit the fucking buttons.
Hit my button.
You clicked auction.
Just hit it.
Hit okay.
I didn't touch it.
Hit okay, Pippa.
My hands are under the desk.
My game crashed.
Luffy.
Okay.
Don't worry.
Oh, she hit it.
There we go.
We got it.
Game crashed?
No.
Okay, wait.
Can I buy the auction or what?
Yeah, we can auction this.
I want to bid.
Hey, bid.
No, it's Purple's turn.
Yeah, Purple, it's your turn.
Oh, you want to withdraw?
My game crashed!
Pippa, get it together.
Okay, I'm going to auction it.
I'm going to bid a hundred bucks.
I'm going to have to gig and chat and nobody can stop me.
I have a more up to nerd.
I bid.
What did you bid?
I bid a hundred.
I bid a hundred too.
Whoa, that's fucking rapid.
I bid a hundred as well.
It's a railway.
You know you're bidding on top of our bids, right?
Lumi, you're blue.
You're blue.
No, I'm not.
Oh, I'm blue.
Fuck, Pippa's dead.
Pippa can join back.
It's remote play.
That's the thing.
She can join back whenever.
Pippa, come back.
No, we just hate to make you want to add me.
I'm trying to add you.
You have to invite me.
I have to tab out every time.
I got you.
It's a sacrifice we're willing to make.
She can literally join back any time because it's literally remote play.
Okay, here's what we do.
Thank you.
Doki cares.
I'm like Lumi.
You just like blondes.
This is blondism.
You're blonde.
With everybody distracted, I can do this.
Oh, shit.
Shut up.
This is unfair.
What are you doing?
I'm gonna vlog you.
Doki with the steal.
With the steal.
Everybody was so distracted.
Motherfucker.
Oh my god.
Fuck you, Doki.
Fuck your taxes.
I hate you guys.
I hope we're not friends in a few minutes.
I am not a fan of the government.
Fuck.
I knew this was the right idea.
This is bullshit.
Don't get an extra name on.
Shut up.
Okay, Doki.
If I roll another number and end up on your railroad, I'm gonna come over to your house and effing put a track on your face.
What are you gonna do?
Okay, it's Pippa back in.
Did we get Pippa back in?
We're gonna run.
Ma!
Yeah!
I'm buying it.
Don't click my nerds.
Fine.
Yoinkers.
I'm having Oriental.
And I'm on an avenue.
Alright, here we go.
Yay!
It's my turn!
I already got a property before I win.
Is that crazy, guys?
Shut up.
You're gonna be broke.
Fuck up.
No!
Where are you going?
Yay!
I'm going to seven.
I got a car!
You have no sound effect.
If that's the nearest railroad, if unknown, you may buy it from the bank.
If owned, pay owner twice.
The rent to which they are otherwise entitled.
What?
Oh, I can buy it too?
Oh my god!
Everything is going for Zoki!
This is fucking bullshit.
I'm telling you this is your fault.
It's not my fault.
It's my fault.
But to be fair, it's all our fault.
It's all our fault.
It's also Philly's fault.
I'm kidding.
You can't just blame it.
I'm not Obama.
Don't blame it on me.
I'm letting you in.
I'm not going to trade with anybody.
Do I just end my turn?
What happened to the spirit of teamwork?
Yay!
I have two railroads now.
Do we invite Pippa back?
Yo, Zoki, team up.
Check your PayPal.
No!
Lumi, silence!
The women are speaking.
Zoki.
Please.
Team up with me.
What do I get out of it?
What do I get out of it though?
Roads to rail.
Okay, but like how many roads though?
You heard of Pipp's sexual.
Now get ready for a boulevardian.
What?
What the fuck is this Pippa lock?
Did Pippa even like...
Okay, is that Pippa playing?
She actually passed through me.
You're a Sanifax dog?
Holy frick.
What the hell?
How do we build the houses again?
You have to own all the colors.
You just have to land on it again.
And then you can build a house.
You have to land on it again.
Did you have a bubble?
Okay, give me the fucking property.
Yes, buy.
No auction.
No!
I want to get the blue one.
I love the blue property.
I didn't click anything.
What do you mean?
I really only did one.
Will you have the history?
Oh, because I did it once.
I have a history.
Oh my god.
That's what it means.
You did it before.
Oh my god.
You have to buy the entire planet.
Stop.
My stocks are going up.
Okay, it's my turn.
Please give me a double.
Land on my property, coward.
You won't.
Shut up.
I would rather go to jail.
I like trains.
No!
You haven't done the crime yet.
You haven't got caught.
Oh my god.
Tax evasion does fail.
You haven't got caught yet.
You're so lucky.
Is that the end of my turn?
Yeah, that is.
Just press enter for me.
Okay, I'll press enter for you.
It's your turn.
I have nothing going for me.
Oh, I got the pass.
Free parking.
You just won $5.
Congrats.
I did it.
Parking is expensive.
Parking is actually pretty expensive in downtown.
Who's that?
You guys are all landing on properties.
That's unfair.
Tell me about it.
I own a singular blue property.
That's called karma.
We don't control other people's thoughts.
Does anyone want to auction their property off?
Yes, yes, yes.
I would like to auction.
I would like to auction jail.
It's a government property.
I'll steal it.
You want to auction it off?
No, no, no.
I'm good.
It's good.
I'm literally behind you guys and I get to auction literally nothing.
Buy nothing.
I'm going to land on someone's property.
You have no property.
I didn't commit tax fraud.
Why do you have one property?
No, I visited EDP.
He said it was a really good cupcake.
I don't know what you won from me.
Let me roll.
I just killed myself.
What?
I got a double.
Okay, we're still back.
Wait, is this really good?
Yeah, this is electric company.
You own electricity.
Chat.
I'm now in a water type Pokemon.
Thundera!
Now we have to pay Thillion for looming.
Yeah, pay me every time internet crashes.
Crack, pull me Comcast.
I hate Comcast.
I'm going to fiber.
I'm moving and I'm getting fiber.
Fuck you, me.
Look at my eyes.
Turn up the SFX volume in chat.
He wants to hear something.
Why is it 25, dude?
Because it's fucking loud.
It's not loud at all.
It's so loud.
You don't need these sounds.
Okay, we don't need 25.
I don't mind.
It's louder than everything else in the game.
Just pick up your phone.
Do you like trains?
Yes or no?
I don't give a goddamn mind.
Knockers acoustic.
Okay.
Roll your dice.
Please roll your dice.
I'm dead again.
What the fuck?
Who did I roll before?
Wait, does anyone own this?
I don't think so.
We are so Barack.
We are so Barack, boys.
St. James Place.
I'm going to touch it and purchase it.
There it is.
Why did you wear it like that?
Call yourself Fillion Rockefeller.
Yeah, my turn.
Yup, yup.
Chat, I'm about to run an effing Monopoly on these effing nerds.
Wait, that's the game.
You're doing so good, Fillion.
Okay, let me go.
Does anyone own... nobody owns these properties.
Damn, so close.
Nice.
Now you can have the red.
It's mine now.
Man.
That's right.
I mean, I'll sell it to you.
I'll sell it to you, Lumi.
How about the games?
I'm going to tell about the games.
Look, real estate is like really...
It's a difficult market right now.
Pay school fees.
You're going back to school.
Oh, look, you're going broke.
You're going broke, nerd.
Congratulations on graduating.
I mean, $50 for student debt.
That's pretty...
That's a good deal.
Bargain.
That's pretty good.
How many properties do you guys own?
I own three.
I can't do this effects at all.
I hear it.
It says there's not a lot of sound effects.
It's just go...
Yeah, I know, but they're still laughing low.
Like what?
What do you want them to be?
It's just going to be like a ding sound or whatever.
I know, I know.
I want to hear my dings.
She wants to hear her dings, guys.
People will literally grind for 30 hours in RuneScape to hear her sing her ding when they level up.
Her attention span is so low that she needs to hear her dings.
Thanks for the galaxy!
Oh wow!
100 guzzies!
Guzzy overdrive enabled.
Did you crash us?
No.
No, she's trying to lower her volumes and stuff.
I'm trying to lower the volume on my side.
It's literally a ding sound effect.
I swear, this collab has been the hardest to sound balance in my life.
In between everyone yelling?
In between everyone fucking yelling?
This has been the...
My sound guy really like gave up.
Yeah, it's been a little...
Double!
Double?
Dude, that's not fair.
And she gets a...
Gimme, gimme, gimme, gimme.
Woo!
Pacific Gap!
Oh my god.
She's getting the expensive properties now.
Hell yeah.
Don't come to California, nerd.
No, she's gonna be too broke to buy boardwalk.
No, she can afford it.
No, she haven't skipped it.
I still have 600.
Nice boardwalk now.
I passed go.
Was that my real...
No, it's just a community chest.
Oh!
Oh no, she killed...
My dog died!
Did you come to life insurance on your dog?
For money.
That's fucked up.
My dog died.
That's fucked up because life insurance doesn't mean old age.
What did you do to your dog?
Nothing, nothing.
Don't worry about it.
Don't worry about your little doggy piece face.
Please, please, please.
You can't grab life insurance if it's old age.
You can't?
No, you can't.
Because they would never give you life insurance if it's like...
Okay, thank you.
Wait, who am I trade with?
We don't want to trade with.
Why are you trading?
Oh, somebody clicked trade.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my god, if somebody pressed N, she's out.
No, stop, stop.
There's a bank club button.
It would be a shame if somebody just pressed N.
What the fuck?
Oh, she's going to jail.
Listen.
You might as well be bankrupt.
God dang it, dude.
Get fucked, Billy.
Why am I in the good log?
I literally rolled a double.
Does that make me invincible?
No.
That's just proof that you stacked the dice.
Yeah, that was illegal.
You just did an illegal thing.
Why the hell did you play my game like that?
You're just mad because I'm putting a bulletin down and I'm about to buy boardwalk when I grow up.
And you guys have the wrong reward.
It's true.
My turn.
Let's see.
Does anyone own that?
Nope.
Is that another utility?
Oh, you can have a monopoly on the utility now.
I own the water.
Okay.
You own the water and I own the effing electricity.
We can put them together and create toasters and bathtubs.
We can sell this as a product for Darwinism.
What do you think?
What the fuck?
This is exactly why she's in jail.
This is why we've kept her in jail.
I'm not in jail.
I'm visiting.
You're definitely in jail right now.
I'm just...
I'm doing nothing.
Oh, and money!
Thank you, Pippa.
Okay.
Yay!
I knew owning that railway that Pippa auctioned off was a good idea.
I'm doing three days in a row.
Shut up.
Wait, who's this to me?
You can't roll again.
You got snake eyes.
You got doubles.
Pippa, bail me out of jail.
No!
Go say hi to me.
She needs some company.
Don't leave me.
She's gonna influence you.
Bye.
Get taxed, idiot.
It's my land.
Okay, here.
Oh, you actually press trade.
What?
You actually press trade.
No, no, no.
Please trade with me.
Are you the bear?
Yeah, I'm the bear.
What do you want to trade?
Here, I'll give you...
I'll give you...
Enough to get out of jail?
Wait, what?
What the...
Are you gonna post your bail?
Why are you bailing her out?
You gotta give me something.
What do you want?
What do you...
She wants...
She wants your electricity.
You would do that to me?
I would.
You think I'm gonna give up my early investments just because you're gonna give me an effing...
You're trying to dogecoin me.
You're trying to pump and dump me.
It's a very good deal.
You made $5.00.
You're not in my scam.
Like, honestly, I feel like you're in jail right now, Fillion.
You should not be negotiating.
You know what, Fillion?
You know what?
Fillion, blink twice.
Are you just gonna quit the game?
No, no, no.
The first rage quitter right here.
I'm gonna counter offer.
Here's my counter offer, okay?
I'm gonna remove...
How do I play?
You have to remove it on your own screen.
On your side, you see your side with all the cards?
You gotta click it on yourself.
Oh...
What?
Underneath your money.
You see all those cards on the right side?
Just click...
Obviously, no, because your cursor's not on it.
Obviously, I know you don't understand.
Yes, okay, there you go.
There.
No, you don't wanna know.
Frick this.
How do I...
Just double click it.
Yeah, if you don't want it, just click it again.
How?
Press... Okay, click it and then press remove.
No, I'm not interested.
Click it and then press enter because it removes the card.
I'm not interested.
Okay, fine.
Yeah.
What the fuck?
Fillion!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Almost there.
Yeah?
Honestly, like, I'm impressed that Fillion's making these demands when she's in fucking jail.
Alright, you have nothing.
Alright, how do I...
Pippa's literally visiting...
Pippa's literally visiting you in jail, like, the only person that's willing to visit you.
She brought you your favorite brownies and shit?
Yeah, and all the rest of us just pretends you don't...
pretend you don't exist right now.
Can you stop?
I hate you.
When I get out of jail, I'm gonna become the next Warren Buffet and you're gonna be the buffet.
You understand me?
I don't think you're able to because you're literally... you literally have a police record.
No one's gonna hire you now.
Yeah, you're unhirable.
Who's gonna hire you?
I don't know who the fuck you own.
And when you walk into the store, like, Gustavo afraid to check on your lawyers, I'm gonna stab you in the neck with a shank.
I just won't go there.
Okay, I lied.
I'd actually be like, what do you want?
You'd be like, number seven.
I'd be like, sorry, the ice cream machine broke.
Okay, how do I say I'm not interested?
Like what is this effing left arrow?
It's back space.
Back space.
Is that the bottom of this exchange?
Fillion, I'd order burgers from you.
Okay.
See, you have a customer.
Roll the dice.
I'm just, uh, I'm just happy.
Ooh, Doug.
I'm doing my own thing and I'm not going to... Oh, Fillion!
You're going to visit?
Oh my god!
You're going to visit Fillion?
I'm so sad that you're a girl!
Oh man!
Lumi's just visiting so she feels more superior than her.
Lumi, if you feel so bad for me, why don't you give me a small loan of a million?
Yeah, bye.
Okay, see you later.
No, I'm good.
Pass.
I'm good.
All my friends are dead, yo.
Push me to the edge.
Ah, sucks, sucks.
Sucks to suck, Fillion.
Fuck!
Hey, how about you pay me $14?
Nice, I brought you lunch.
I brought you pizza to the jail.
Oh yeah, you tried to run away from me and I haven't caught you.
You tried to run, I quick-scoped you on the way out.
Okay, wait, I can roll dice three times or I can pay 50 bucks.
You have to roll a double, I think, to get out?
Just pay $50!
It's literally 50!
Shut up, woman!
I don't want no dice!
Keep her in jail, Dokie!
Keep her!
Yeah, but what if you don't tell?
Try it, idiot.
If you don't get the number, then you'll never get out!
I should've paid the 50.
I told you, you should've paid the 50!
Nobody listens to me!
Look how nobody listens to me about Monopoly!
You're not having fun doing this, Dokie!
Shut up, look at this trotty on Twitter!
Hashtag free my boy, Fillion.
Let's not, that would be like the fastest way to die.
Look, I got through double.
There she goes.
There I go!
Is that a chance card?
Whoa, I'm pretty sure I'm gonna pay.
If that's the nearest railroad...
Oh, another railroad?
Do I own this?
Fuck, man!
Oh, I own this!
This is insane luck!
Okay, but I don't own... I already own this, so I don't get to buy it.
Free for a penile fill-in.
Another double?
Let's go!
I hope you go to jail.
This is fucked up.
The system is broken.
What is this?
Wait, is this jail?
Oh, rigs!
I hate capitalism!
No, it's another community chest.
Let's go!
Oh my god!
This is garbage.
Garbage.
It's my birthday!
What the fuck?
Happy birthday!
You fucking die!
Oh my god!
You fucking liar!
Thank you guys!
It's my birthday!
Yeah, happy 50th.
Happy 50th.
I hope you get out of the rabbit hole.
Dude, I'm gonna get in jail and I bought you a birthday gift.
Okay, nice.
Alright, thank god.
Alright, that's good.
Yeah!
I'm fine!
I got birthday money!
Let's go!
I just got birthday money too!
Oh my god.
Dude, this is so stupid, man!
Hey, I got two of your doubles, Vilian.
Maybe you should have paid 50 fucking dollars.
Why did I get skipped though?
Why did I get skipped?
This is madness.
This could have been you if you paid your fucking money.
Wait, but I didn't, like... Why did I get to roll again?
No, you didn't.
You only got to roll once.
Oh, you owed money.
You're so nice.
You're so good to the homeless people.
Yeah.
Catgirl losing to a little tomato.
Look, she's giving you another bail option.
Who is doing this now?
Come on, Vilian.
I'm not giving you my property, okay?
Sorry, I love my women too much.
Calm down, Vivian.
Take it back!
Dude, I'm not gonna give you my money or my property.
I need it.
I'm not asking for your money!
You're never gonna play, Vilian, if you...
I'm not a laughing Monopoly god.
I know that property is worth that much.
That's a good deal, Vilian.
No, I know it's worth that much.
I don't want this.
I'm not interested.
That's a good deal.
I know what I'm worth.
You're gonna make a deal?
Yeah, I know what I'm worth.
Out of commitment?
She's literally in jail.
She's scared of everything right now.
Like, I don't know what's going on in jail, but I'm pretty sure.
That's shit, so bad.
Bad shit.
Okay.
Changes a person.
I wonder what the player...
She just needs more time in jail to finally get desperate.
Look, everybody's getting doubles except for you, Vilian.
Yeah.
Are you even supersizing your menu?
That says something about you.
Oh,
nice!
Oh, shit.
I'm gonna go to jail.
I'm gonna roll a double and get boardwalked.
It's a nice Monopoly.
Bye.
No more Monopoly.
Oh, but there's still the green.
The green's...
Kill me.
Alright, here's another chance.
Or you can pay $50.
Shut up.
I'm gonna pay.
Okay, fine.
Welcome back.
Welcome back, Vilian.
Call it jail time.
How was jail?
You're a millionaire committing a crime.
Alright, let me roll my dice.
Did you enjoy the spam?
Yeah.
Oh, my butt hurts.
See?
You weren't gonna get a double anyway.
Hey, look at you.
You got community checks.
It would be funny if she goes to the jail again.
Alright.
If this goes to jail, I'm gonna uninstall.
Hey, you got $25.
Consultancy fees.
Yeah, you got...
They catered me for advice.
Who?
Who's they?
Because they're not taking money from us.
My viewers donated $5.
What?
Who owns this?
$25 to get Vilian out of jail.
Wait.
Does no one own this?
No, fuck you.
Oh, my God.
I got more trains.
I got another railroad.
I'm gonna kill this bitch.
Guys.
I'm owning the train.
I'm gonna buy transportation.
Hello, fellow unlucky people of the Monopoly board.
I would like to propose an alliance.
Wait.
Who are you proposing to?
I'm proposing an alliance against Doggy Bird.
Me?
What did I do?
She's got too much generational wealth.
I don't like it.
I just owned...
I literally just bought the railroad.
I feel unsafe.
What do you mean I made my money?
You're paying Doggy right now.
It's okay.
I'm gonna buy Boardwalk right now.
Yeah, okay.
Yeah, sure.
And like two turns.
One is my turn, but you know.
Yeah, okay.
Two turns.
She's gonna get Boardwalk.
We believe in you.
Just effing let me cook.
Shit.
Oh, you get the green.
That's not owned by anybody.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Okay, I take it.
Wait, you're gonna own that Monopoly.
No, dude.
Oh, wait.
I can have a Monopoly.
Yeah, you just need the green one.
Pennsylvania.
I have a Monopoly.
I can get a Monopoly.
Dude, let me own a property.
Please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please.
I'm gonna scream.
Eight, is that good or bad?
Whoa, we'll see.
Please.
I think she's gonna have a Monopoly.
Wait, no.
She just bought that, didn't she?
Yeah.
I just bought that.
Oh, god.
Don't be a bird girl.
That's just.
I can bite her.
He is.
Excuse me.
Wait, you have a three, and you have a three.
Do you own any railroad stations?
Yeah, I do.
Okay, Lumi, you wanna do an alliance?
I can own the railroads.
And you can own the property.
Lumi, shit!
I mean, you should have an alliance because I literally own the one monopoly you own.
Oh my god!
Chad, is this real?
I offer you...
Lumi, I offer you...
I offer you one red space for your green space.
This is real, Chad.
Alright, you know what?
Yeah, I'll take that deal.
Okay, okay, okay.
Good deal, good deal.
Does anyone like giving money?
This has been one of the best trade deals in American history.
I'm gonna jump.
Hey!
Wow, this is crazy.
This is crazy.
That's insane.
Oh, okay.
What are you giving here?
What do you want from me?
I'm breaking this alliance.
I'm gonna do it three times before it starts.
You're gonna need a lot of power.
I bet you're attracted to power, actually.
Don't you like that?
Pippa, do you want to be part of this alliance?
We can do it three ways.
Wait, what about this?
She's disestablishmentarian.
I believe in the government.
Or I don't, depending on what you like.
I need my green monopoly, Pippa.
Yeah, she can have her green monopoly.
I can have my red monopoly.
Everybody is happy.
If you trade away your red, she'll never get the green monopoly.
And don't you want her to be happy?
I'll give you an orange if you give me a yellow.
I'm not in this business meeting, dude.
You went to jail.
You can't be in this business meeting.
You have a record.
I can't.
You can't let you in right now.
I can call Wester.
Someone offer me something?
If you want, you can either have an orange or a green.
I'll take the orange.
You literally have two properties.
What are you going to offer us?
I can offer you my love.
You have two properties.
This is the problem with America.
Okay.
Do this deal with Halloween.
Yeah, deal.
Sure.
Throw in 50 bucks.
Do it.
I'll take it.
Just do counter offer and then you can make her throw in.
No, this one is for Pippa.
Thank you.
She needs it right now.
Shut up.
Love is Christmas.
Is it my turn?
No.
You're after this.
87 turns and I have zero.
She was so close to boardwalk.
She was almost there.
Someone has to get that.
You don't own any.
You don't own houses or hotels.
Good.
We can trade if you want.
Yeah, let's trade.
Trade me.
You're not part of this conversation.
Who are you?
You want the green.
Yeah.
And then I'll give you the green.
Okay.
This is a good trade.
How do I do it?
Press it and then enter.
Add.
Nice.
Yeah.
And then...
You know what?
If you're generous right now, I'll give you that deal.
Thank you.
Wow.
Oh, sorry.
Deal.
Yes.
Wow.
Accept.
I'm happy with this monopoly.
I'm happy with this monopoly as well.
Yes.
The first monopoly, guys.
What is wrong?
I can build houses.
Woo!
Alright.
Get ready to enter.
I can't build anything.
It's my turn.
It's your turn.
You guys hurry up.
Get on the property.
I'm not about to spend the next 2 hours screaming over being broke.
Oh hey, thank you again for the water.
I mean, people need a shower, so it's understandable, Fillian, that you need a shower.
I have a very special set of skills.
It's very, very nice of you.
And I will give you a hug in real life.
Oh, nice.
You're welcome.
With a shotgun.
In the shower.
There's your water bills, bitch.
I'll take the water that I paid 15 bucks for and give it back to you.
And then I'll ask for a refund.
Now I can see why Fillion went to jail, guys.
Why?
She's a dangerous axe murderer.
I went to jail because I paid back my crime.
She's a dangerous society.
I'm not.
I'm a danger to myself.
Oh, doubles.
I got a double.
Does anyone own that?
Just so you guys know, I have more money than all of you.
Yeah, because you never bought anything.
So?
No!
I have to pay 200.
I have to pay taxes.
I didn't even lost.
That's crazy.
I'm too rich now.
I got to the next tax bracket.
That's what you said about my property.
Now I'm gonna be visiting.
I'm gonna visit jail.
Yo, tell her to be high.
Alright.
I can't believe it.
I fucking... I went to the next tax bracket.
She's looking at the less fortunate people to remind her of how she came up.
I was trying to remind myself to be like, I'll never be like Fillion.
Okay.
I'm a robot.
Nice, Peppa.
Oh, you got Monopoly too.
We all got Monopoly.
Yeah!
We all got Monopoly now.
All three of us.
Wait,
Doggy.
Do you want to trade me water?
No.
At least give me a chance.
I know you have to pay.
I have nothing I want.
I got eliminated on M-stream and I don't win any.
You literally have nothing I want.
I have a railroad!
Oh, you get to go back and go again.
You reset itself.
Hey, look at that.
You got $400.
Money.
I like how nobody has landed on Boardwalk yet.
No.
This might be Fillion's chance.
I believe in you, Fillion.
You know, there have to be poor people to remind us about the poor people, Cheetah.
I know, you're right.
Fillion's like the one who reminds us where we started.
Oh, look, you got community chairs.
Oh, you don't have to pay.
You don't own anything.
So you don't have to pay.
Oh, she's too poor.
She doesn't even have taxes to pay.
Yeah.
I mean, it's nice that she finds pleasure in the little things.
She's here to remind us about that.
Cheetah, you do have a chance.
What is this?
Oh, is this an art community chest?
Oh my god.
Nobody's getting these last two years.
Nobody.
Oh my god, get a jump-free card.
Cheetah, you want to trade?
This is truly a privilege of the rich.
Yeah, I'll trade.
That is such a rich privilege.
I'll give you $50.
No, that's not worth $50.
I'll give you $60.
I'll give you $69.
Keep going up.
All you have is money.
Yeah, all you have is money.
Wait, she's ready.
Oh, thank god.
I still have a chance.
Oh, you luxury tax.
Pippa bought so many nice things.
Wait, you're about to go broke, nerd.
Until you land on my square.
How does it feel?
You're gonna land on my houses and you're gonna be like, Oh, I'm so sorry, Pippa.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
Let's go.
Bye.
Bye, that shit.
Hell yeah.
Mods.
Your mods can't help you now, Fillion.
Okay.
I just need to get a 1, 2, 3...
I need a 4 or a 6.
If I get a 4 or a 6, I am more Barack than Obama.
She is literally...
She's gonna be back.
Are you kidding me?
Wow.
I'm getting assholes.
She's not back.
She is not back at all.
Hey, Fillion, you know you're supposed to buy the land, right?
Yeah.
Wait, how much property does she have?
I don't think Indians have rights.
Just 3.
Wait, she's preventing you from getting a monopoly, Lumi.
You should trade with her.
Oh, hey, Fillion.
What up?
Maybe what you're offering, sister.
I'll give you...
I'll give you the blue spot.
I'll give you that little light blue one.
Okay.
Wait, make the deal.
Give me a deal, dog.
Which one are you?
You're the dog or the hat?
I'm the hat.
Alright, hat.
I think make an offer.
Alright, here's my offer.
Don't forget, I'm on the left.
You give me this orange thing.
Okay, you want my orange thing?
4.
And then I give you...
How do I fucking do it?
Motherfucker.
You give me the blue one.
And then what?
How do I do it?
Oh, not so easy now, is it?
My thumb doesn't work.
You hover over to yourself.
That's how you do it.
I'll give you this blue thing.
There you go.
You are such a nerd.
I'll throw in a hundred dollars.
So you can get out of jail twice.
No, no.
I want two hundred.
You should take the money, Fillion.
I'll give you two hundred.
I'm giving you two monopolies.
No, I said two hundred.
I said...
You have way too much money.
I'm not going bankrupt.
You're never getting a property.
I'm giving you a property.
I don't.
Yeah, I know.
And you're getting a second.
Here's the plan.
We wait until Fillion gets bankrupt.
And then you can take the property for free.
Fillion, look.
I know you're not good at investing.
But I promise.
If I give you this property, you'll have a chance to survive.
Shut up, dog.
I said two hundred.
I know.
Look.
You didn't go to school.
This is hard to drive.
You owe me money.
Investments, Fillion.
I said give me two hundred.
I said two hundred.
She's a lost cause.
Don't help her.
I said two hundred.
She's gonna drag you down, Lumi.
She's gonna make you go down and back to jail.
I'll give her two hundred.
No, Lumi.
Listen to her.
I'll give her two hundred.
It's fine.
What's she gonna do with it besides pay her monopolies?
You're getting scammed.
No, this will pay off in the long run.
I have faith.
I'll give you two hundred and one dollars.
When she goes on an egomaniacal rampage because she has a monopoly?
She'll probably just trip on her treadmill.
She's three blue squares.
I'm only gonna own two.
She's just gonna trip on her fucking treadmill again.
Are you guys done?
Okay, I want two hundred and five for that joke.
No, motherfucker!
I want two hundred and five now.
She's just asking and asking and asking.
No, no, no.
Don't do it, Lumi.
No, not interested.
Not interested.
No, fuck you.
She needs to be put in her place.
That's fine.
Half of a hotdog?
Half of a hotdog.
She's a lost cause.
You can't keep stupid.
I'm gonna roll one right now.
Check this out.
Alright, do it.
Nice roll.
Alright, my turn.
Yay!
I'm so fucking scared every time Doki rolls the dice.
Why are you guys scared?
She's got everything.
Oh no!
Who's this?
It's Pippa!
Holy shit!
Now I'm scared.
Fuck!
I don't like this Pippa Monopoly.
Pippa has a Monopoly now.
She's getting rich.
She was the hidden...
The secret...
You could have prevented this.
This is all your fault, Fillion.
She was the secret business mongrel.
It's all your fault.
This was Fillion's fault, yeah.
Why am I an epic McDonald's employee, dude?
I just... what are these rolls, dude?
What?
And she gets 150?
She was the hidden!
The capipalism is so fucking strong today.
Don't like this.
Wait, can I manage my properties?
I managed my properties.
Manage...
I should have managed my properties too.
Oh my god, it's so much money.
Sure.
Wait, how do I do it?
It's shift?
Yeah.
Oh my god, it's so fucking expensive!
It is.
Jesus.
Okay, I'm just gonna play.
Cause I still got properties to buy.
Wait.
Fuck.
Seven?
Where's seven?
Oh, yeah, it's a dragon!
Oh, it's fine, it's fine.
Someone should hurry and own this.
No, you go stay high on my phone, my boy.
You know, keep me humble, that's all.
Keep me humble.
You go stay high on my phone.
I will buy another property.
But you're gonna be broke.
You're gonna be broke soon, Lumi.
It should be fine, it should be fine.
Oh my god, how do I do this?
What are you doing?
You go back, back.
Headbang for content reasons.
Okay, my turn.
My turn, my turn!
I'm gonna roll a one.
You can't, you literally can't.
You literally can't even roll a one.
I'm on my way!
To tomato town.
What is this, what is this, what is this?
Fuck.
You owe $200.
Wow, what a time, Billy.
Stop!
Please, please, please, please, Billy, please.
Great job.
Please, please, please.
When was the last time you bought property, by the way?
What is this?
Like her second turn of the game.
Oh, I can roll again.
Great, okay.
Wow, I sure can't wait to land on a railroad.
Hey look, you can't land on a railroad.
You can't get one.
You get to visit Jailer's World!
Hey!
Hey, you just visiting your friend's village?
I'm gonna shake you in a jail cell and I'm never gonna find you.
You're just visiting!
There's guards around you!
There's guards, Billy!
I'm a level 7 rogue and I took soccer feet off my feet.
I feel unsafe.
I feel like I'm gonna die.
Yeah, I feel unsafe.
Who owns this?
Nobody owns it.
Oh, no, you own it!
Oh, I gave you that.
Remember, I gave you this.
Yeah, you did.
So, wait, guys, did I promise?
If I'm gonna jump over what I did for you...
You'll bail me out?
I wonder, like, where's my...
I would bail Doki out.
Yeah, I bailed out.
This is a Pheebs thing, you know?
I put a whole new thing.
What about, like, a Fillion thing?
No, you're not included.
You're not included.
You were in jail.
My blood pressure is so high, I'm about to burst a basket.
Guys, there's a potential where I might go bankrupt.
You cannot tell me this game is based on skill.
It's all skill.
It's all about investing.
It's not.
You would understand if you went to school.
Okay, Lumi.
Lumi.
You wanna trade or not?
Yeah, yeah, let's do the trade.
Okay, we'll do the trade on your next turn.
You give me the orange, I give you the blue.
Okay.
We'll do it.
Oh my god, Pippa's all in on her Monopoly.
That's fucking scary.
I don't like that.
Yeah, she has a... she has a scary Monopoly right now.
Wooo.
Where is she going?
Oh!
God damn it.
What comes around goes around.
Oh!
You got me!
What is happening?
You really went too much!
Oh, shit.
That's what you get.
What do you want?
Taliyah, I'll come and make a deal.
Okay, what's the deal?
Tell me now.
Look, and this is how it goes.
And this is how it goes.
Oh, yeah, stay in the office.
You offered me a property and you want...
She's a fucking loan shark.
What do you want?
What do you want from me?
Okay, you can stop.
Stop.
A little more, Pippa.
A little more.
You don't have to pay for it.
She's desperate.
No, she's so desperate.
It's so hard.
It's one night and night.
Let me negotiate.
You can literally ask for more money.
You know she wants a property.
She's so fucking desperate.
You have to ask for more.
I know everything we do for the business and I can make sure you're a millionaire.
You know she'll say yes if you ask for more money.
You don't have to pay it.
She's offering more.
We got property!
More!
Get a hundred though.
Hell yeah.
I overpay much, but it's fine.
Let me not touch Pippa's land.
It freaks me out.
She's gonna shoot me with a shotgun.
I will.
Who is it?
Motherfucker!
Thank god!
I was honestly scared.
I was gonna go bankrupt.
But everything seems to go well.
Okay, let's trade.
Let's trade, Lumi.
It all comes back to you.
You're such a good old fill-in.
I'll give you Connecticut Ave.
Just because of railroads?
Railroads aren't even a monopoly.
You can't monopolize railroads.
This country was built on railroads, Doki.
This country was built on the backbone of our whole society.
I'm Canadian.
Chat!
What the fuck?
Can I miss $2?
I threw that troll too hard.
T-shut up.
Motherfucker.
Whatever, man.
I f-ing leave.
Thank you!
If I get the last blue one, I promise I'll give it to you.
Shut up.
Never mind.
I love you.
She insulted you after you traded with her.
No, no, no.
I didn't say shit.
I just spoke with my...
I just spoke with my...my brain spoke before I did.
Sorry.
I broke my dipstick.
I don't think you should put more property.
You have like $100.
The moment you land on another...
Can someone land on a space please?
That's me!
It's your turn.
Chat, watch me roll boardwalk.
I think you're way too far.
You're way too far from boardwalk.
Welcome to the deck, baby.
Look at everybody using my railroad.
Donkey, donkey, donkey.
You know I'm rich, right?
I give you the 100, you trade me back, I owe you one.
Yeah, but why are you going to trade for it?
I want a property.
I don't want a property.
Two fold.
Right?
I want a property, Fillion.
Okay, sorry.
I love my family and my wife and I can't afford to feed them without them.
I can give it to you.
What?
Over time.
But you're not the trustee.
But if you trade them away...
You trade your family away, you never have to feed them again.
Okay, but here's the thing.
Here's the thing.
I only love my mom and my bed.
I'm sorry.
Oh my god.
So I will trade you back eventually.
How old are you, man?
Who crashed?
Let me...
Wait, shit, shit, shit.
You crashed?
No, somebody crashed.
Oh wait, nobody crashed?
No, you just tabbed out.
Oh, you tabbed out.
Okay, okay.
Donkey, you're going to pay me back.
I tabbed out.
Yeah, yeah.
Donkey, you're going to pay me back.
You're going to pay me back.
No deal.
We trade.
No deal, affiliate.
Someone put an end to it for me.
No deal.
Somebody quit looking for me.
Yay!
I was so scared.
Okay, she can't get the blues.
Don't worry, we're still safe on Boardwalk.
Yeah, Boardwalk is still safe.
Boardwalk is not.
I got it.
Is this the loomy?
Aw, it's the loomy territory.
Yay!
Oh, it's $4.
Oh, thank god.
Nice!
You know what?
You gave me $100, I'll give you $4.
Thanks, thanks, Donkey.
Thanks.
I appreciate it.
Hey, yeah, what's $4 between friends?
Exactly, right?
Pippa, roll a four.
Shit!
Pippa, you just touched me.
Nine.
Wait, I said three!
Human doppelgangers gotta stick together.
Wait, we're getting more money, bro.
Wait, who the fuck is this?
Oh, that's me!
That's the one I put a house on!
What?
That's the 100!
I made one!
All I'm saying, Pippa, is you allied with the wrong person!
No, no, no, no, no!
Chad, are we cooked?
Shit, we're fucked in this game.
I just...
She's the only one with a house, too.
She's the only one with the house, too.
She's rich in the B-I-O-0 property!
Oh my god!
Oh, my god!
I fucking hate this shit.
I fucking hate this.
I'm actually going to blow up this fucking chain.
Oh my god!
I'm not gonna blow up this fucking train.
Oh my god, I was broke and now I'm rich!
I'm blowing up this train.
Okay, come on, come on, come on, come on.
Boardwalk, boardwalk, boardwalk, I'm charging up my dice.
YIKED!
Look, all I'm saying to me is that we gotta stick together.
We do, we do.
I'll give you whatever free change we got, man.
Are you gonna land on another railroad?
Nice, William!
Nice!
Welcome!
Welcome to the train station, William.
Welcome to my train station.
Alright, I watched the Constance Wilds.
Who would've thought owning transportation was like the way to go?
Who would've thought?
I don't wanna get off Mr. Bones' wild ride.
Okay, bump and roll again.
Watch, boardwalk.
Bop!
Oh hey, snake eyes.
Double!
It's over, it's over, it's over, it's over, it's over, it's over, it's over.
Oh my god!
Fitbit, look, you got saved from bankruptcy!
Hi!
You did it!
Oh, you scared me.
Welcome back, Ginga.
Thank you, Fillion.
Welcome back.
Fillion, would you like to make a deal?
Fillion?
I don't think Fillion is okay.
I think she's like...
I think she regrets suggesting Monopoly as her collab game.
Is that her neck breaking?
I think it's great that Fillion is like our piggy bank.
You know?
Like...
Yeah!
She's like a loan shark but without the muscle.
Yeah, yeah.
So like, she's not a shark, she's like a...
She's like...
She's like a loan ant.
Wait, what the fuck?
You got three doubles, Fillion?
No, she got... she was lucky and got out of jail.
Who's that over there?
What's over there?
No, she just missed it.
Oh, she got...
You know, if you hit that railroad, you could've...
Cut me from having the last railroad.
You could've just straightened the Monopoly.
Yeah.
You were the chosen one, Fillion.
You fucking ruined it all.
You could've stopped me from Monopoly on the trains.
Someone press enter for me.
Why'd you pass that up?
Someone press enter.
Why can't you advance...
Oh!
She got board... she can't afford boardwalk!
Because she's cheating points!
With what?
Money?
Money is weird.
This is crazy!
She can't afford it!
No one's gonna get it!
This is crazy!
I spent my entire life shooting for boardwalk!
You can't even afford it!
It's time for the auction!
Pippa win this!
Pippa!
Wait, wait!
Okay, I'll bid, I'll bid, I'll bid, I'll bid.
You can only bid like...
You can't even afford it!
No!
I draw!
You have to withdraw!
Please, please, please!
You have no money!
I'll do anything!
Please!
You don't have to fucking...
Just withdraw!
You can't afford it!
Let me play bro!
What is this shit?
I did the billion!
The billion!
Yay!
This is your fault!
Fillion, thanks for giving me boardwalk!
This is your fault, Fillion!
I really appreciate it, Fillion!
I didn't discount who...
This is absolutely your fault, Fillion!
I told you guys to not ally with her!
I told you guys!
I'm like DJ Khaled and people didn't make him famous!
Nobody believed me!
I said like it's not... we shouldn't... we shouldn't alliance with her, guys!
I'm putting one of us down here again!
I'm not going!
And I'm gonna have an epic netbook and show!
Like, I can't do this, dude!
I can't do this!
How are we supposed to get more money in this game?
We're just gonna bankrupt ourselves in the next three turns!
Alright, let's see...
What am I gonna do?
I wanna put a house...
I wanna put a house in Indiana!
Welcome to poverty, baby!
Land, bridge, press, core!
Where's my comeback angle?
Oh, I got another die roll!
Let's go!
Yay!
You're just so bad!
This game is not even luck!
Who's this?
Oh, Fillion, you can sell your property to Doki!
Oh, hey!
I love you so much, Doki!
Oh my fucking god!
Sell it to Doki for some money for you!
Yeah, Fillion, you wanna sell me this property, Fillion?
I'm gonna cross-bill and get you a...
Pull yourself up by a bullet...
Yeah, yeah, you wanna sell that property?
I'll buy that property!
No, no!
I'm gonna pass Gogg like $200 and I'll build a kingdom with it!
Yeah, yeah, alright!
Sure!
I play roll for the world, but I can start from nothing!
All I'm saying is Fillion's been coping for a very long time!
Okay, yeah, I like drugs, what about it?
This game is good for your sanity.
You guys like vultures!
You're African Pringle my grave or you're gonna steal whatever's left of me for as cheap as you can get it?
You guys are cursing!
Holy shit!
Oh my god, we should not land on Pippa's spot!
We should not land on any of Pippa's spot!
You're fucking dead if you do!
You're actually fucked!
I'm saying, Fillion, if you land on Pippa's square, I think you actually have to declare bankruptcy!
Thank god!
Thank you, people!
Thank you!
Yay!
I can get out of jail now!
I know you're poor, you needed it!
I'm a player of 4, Chad!
Yeah, yeah, I see what you mean!
Yeah...
This...
I've been on top times!
What's that over there?
Double?
Wait, is that my square?
Does that mean you land on Norwalk?
No!
Oh!
You just missed it!
But you pay it with your attacks!
You're next to me!
Oh my god!
You're a 100!
You...
Fillion...
Stop!
Stop negotiating with her!
I will give you a free pass!
Pippa, give me something!
Donkey?
Pippa!
No!
Okay, I owe you my life.
Yeah?
Okay.
Okay, I'm gonna go.
Okay, I could save you.
I'm giving you what I owe you.
Yeah...
Okay, yeah...
You can give that to me!
Give that to me, Pippa!
Give it to me!
Give it to me, Pippa!
You owe me!
Please, Pippa!
Please!
Come back, Pippa!
You don't even need you!
Still medicine?
You don't even need you...
To be honest, I'm going to have a go, and kiss my girlfriend.
So...
I found a new leader.
It's over.
You're done with you, Flynn.
You're done with...
You're dead on Twitch.
She's done with you, Flynn.
She's done with you.
I cancelled the YouTube rewards.
Sorry.
Freak this junk.
Alicia, why are we all so fucking poor?
I'm going to put my headset.
Okay.
I have over a billion.
Your allies are all gone.
My allies?
Okay.
What is that?
A strategic battle in the west?
Like, what the freak?
You've lost everybody.
You've lost everyone.
Where did I go wrong?
I think that's the one billion spot.
Oh, you got the one billion spot.
But you have enough money.
It's only six dollars.
Like, it's six dollars.
I hope you enjoy the six dollars.
Nice job.
Good money, Flynn.
Good money.
Simple stocks.
What is that over there?
Is that the last railroad?
You got the last railroad!
I fucking can't afford it.
If you give me a hundred dollars...
If you give me a hundred dollars, I'll buy it.
Wait, Pitbull can buy it, right?
Yeah, Pitbull can buy it.
Yeah.
Just let Pitbull buy it.
I have to auction it.
I don't even have options.
No, you auction it off.
You have to auction it off.
I have to auction it.
Just let Pitbull have it.
I'm gonna withdraw it.
She has it automatically.
I got it.
Chad, don't worry.
I'm withdrawing.
Chad, watch this.
You can't...
You can't fucking afford it.
What do you mean?
Just withdraw.
She automatically owns it.
I'm not even
I'm withdrawing.
Oh shit, it's over.
Fuck off.
You can't just put a hundred and fifteen dollars.
Pitbull, you're gonna get bankrupt again.
Was the message really worth it, Pitbull?
I'd like to live it on the edge.
She has the last railroad I need.
She knows she has a card.
You wasted an effing GameStop AAA title worth of money.
She's too powerful.
She just has to be lucky and not land on anything or she's fucked.
It's okay, it's okay.
Chad, watch this.
Boardwalk.
Or no wait, Park Place.
Boardwalk?
You gave me Boardwalk.
Park Place.
Nine?
Is that good?
Yeah.
Is this a good blue?
Oh!
She got her Monopoly!
She owns it!
A Monopoly now!
Holy fuck!
You fucking made it!
Is this real?
She actually made it!
Wait, how do I read this?
Use something to build?
I don't give a frick.
Alright, now what?
Can I buy a house?
Yeah, you can.
Yeah, buy all the houses.
You press enter.
Yes!
Press buttons!
If you get any bankrupt, it's fine.
Oh, really?
How do I...
How do I... here?
Let's go, dude!
Okay.
There she did it.
Now instead of $6, we pay $12, guys.
That's right.
Nice help.
I have a house chat.
I own two houses.
I'm like Drake.
They're mansions.
Who owns this?
Is this mine?
It's my railroad!
I'm safe!
First person gets $100 with a party at my place.
Oh my gosh, put it on Pippa's spot.
This is over for me.
I better not roll bad.
It's fucking over.
For $6.
Uh oh.
Oh, that's... wait, is that Fillion's spot?
It is!
Wait, her luck's turned around!
Oh my god, Fillion!
Her luck is finally turning around!
Wait, wait, that's almost...
Oh, you can't afford it!
Oh my god, Pippa, baby, I give you $8!
Oh, that's right!
You said $8, but then Pippa!
Pippa, I can trade with you.
$9, Pippa.
I can bail you out.
I can bail you out with the exact money you need.
We'll bail you out.
Pippa, Pippa, Pippa, Pippa!
No, Pippa, I'll give you the money back for free!
Pippa, go!
No, please!
Sister!
My sister!
My sister in Christ!
I will give you the money!
You can kill the $24!
You can...
Just don't do it, bro!
You can kill the $24!
This is...
You've doomed us all!
I'm in extreme.
She got her bail!
All I'm saying is that, Pippa, you requested two months.
You requested too much from her.
Fillion, you requested too much from Pippa.
And look what happened!
I gave her the money she needed.
I'm gonna work with you, Doki.
Let's get working with you, Pippa.
This is some fucked up shit.
I'm holding on to my money.
God forbid.
Jesus!
Alright, Fillion, your turn.
I need to press the button.
Alright, yo, what's up, chat?
Oh, frick, I didn't mean to do that.
Okay, whatever.
All I'm saying, Fillion, is that it's not good to be true.
You're too greedy.
Yeah, I win, dude!
What is this?
Oh, it's a property!
Oh, it's community chest.
Student loans, student loans.
Damn!
You get $50!
I bought Amazon!
What?
For $50?
You bought one stock from Amazon.
Fillion Bezos.
I bought a single share of Amazon.
The one stock.
Alright, this is where I die from.
No, chat, walk in.
Walk in, boys.
Oh, okay, I don't die from Pippa.
Look at the fart.
I'm silent and deadly.
Who is this?
Oh, instead I...
Oh, shit, it's Lumi!
No!
I own money!
Oh, man.
Doki.
Lumi.
Doki, what are you...
I'm the richest person here.
No, you're not.
It's Lumi.
How much do you owe again?
130?
I owe 130.
I will give you 150.
I owe you one.
Chat, check this out.
Alright, you know what?
Yeah.
Bail me out if I land on your fucking railroad.
Yeah, I'll bail you out.
Don't worry, I'll bail you out.
Keep me out of your fucking railroad.
I'll give you 140.
There you go, baby.
We got it.
We got each other.
The rich has each other's back, you know?
Alliance.
Alright.
How do we select it?
And then I offer...
I offer...
Wait, how do I add the money?
I've never traded before.
Oh, wait.
No.
What?
I'll take a get out of jail.
Yeah, deal.
Alright, deal.
I'm like Squidward.
Deal.
I'm like Squidward, bro.
Nice.
Nice bail.
Nice, nice.
Who wants to trade me?
Look, Fillion, see this is how you do business, Fillion.
You gotta learn from the best.
Oh my god.
Wait, can I come over to work with you?
You want to be an intern?
Yeah, I wanna be a racist.
Yeah, let me in.
Oh shit, Pippa.
It's okay, it's got no house on it.
Yeah, it's got no house.
Pippa, come here, I'll give you the house.
Pippa!
Hey, Pippa!
How's it going, dude?
What are you trading with her?
Nothing.
What does she have that I don't have?
I think you gotta be blonde, man.
You demand too much, Fillion.
That's the problem.
I told you I'd give you $24 if I didn't give you a fourth railroad.
$1 in exchange for...
Dude, this is pissing me off.
Hey, but she can afford a rent now.
Yeah.
Did you just give her money and then lose money or what?
This is how the rich stays rich.
I bailed her out, man.
I fucking bailed her out.
This is exactly how the rich stays rich.
You know what it is?
I wanna give Fillion money.
You wanna give me cheeks?
Because she wants to be friends with you.
That's what it is.
She's mopping the floor and sandbagging me because she knows I'm gonna keep smelling the syrup and coming back.
And she's gonna keep on smashing me.
And keep on smashing me.
And she knows my entire purpose is to sit in your chat and ride her pee-pee.
She knows it.
And now she's gonna do that.
And maybe I should end stream now!
What the hell are you going on about?
Wait, wait, if Fillion doesn't stream, then her viewers will come watch Lumi and I stream.
So like, that's...
Yeah, Fillion, end stream.
End stream, Fillion.
I'll do it too, Polly.
You won't raid me.
I'll raid you.
I'll give you a...
I'm back, baby!
What's that?
You're back, baby!
You're so back!
Fillion, just so you know, if you raid me, I'll bail you out.
Oh yeah.
We give you offers, Fillion.
I got you, I got you, Fillion.
Yeah, we got you, Fillion.
We fucking got you, man.
Did you just pay $90?
I bet you're jealous that I can do that.
Yay, where am I going?
Where's this?
Is this another chest?
I feel like I always get land on there.
Oh, this is the...
No!
I don't get my 200...
I'm too fucking rich, man!
The tax bracket!
Ratioed, nerd.
Tax bracket, man.
I keep going above the tax bracket.
Oh, another double.
I might go to jail soon, guys.
She's so fucking lucky.
It doesn't even make sense.
No, guys.
If I have one more, I can go to jail.
What do you mean?
That's where you're gonna be in a few minutes.
Oh, oh, oh!
Where's that?
It's my rat-rat!
Oh my god.
I got the fucking chill.
How crazy is that?
I don't want to know.
Canadian taxes hit hard, though.
I don't know.
You land on your own thing, right?
Oh, shit!
You know what?
This is safer.
Yeah, so you're right.
It's actually safer.
Now you wanna go to jail!
Now it's cool to go to jail!
But she's in the rich person jail.
Where she at?
I got a TV in here.
Where she's on the base in Pongchampers.
It's the rich person jail where you get caught for fraud or something.
Oh my god.
Champs?
Oh, you got 200!
That's not effing.
That's not right.
Oh my gosh, she gets another 200.
Okay, Lumi, can you land on my house?
Can you land on my house?
No, no, I have little houses.
No, no, no, I live next door.
I live next door.
I'm good.
I'll pass.
Watch this.
Indiana Avenue.
If you need sugar, you can come over though.
I can buy a house on Indiana Avenue?
Wait, how do I?
You can't.
I mean, you can technically.
Oh yeah, you can buy it on the light blues.
Where am I?
Just keep scoring until there's a green.
I'm pressing down and it's not working, your honor.
There!
There you go.
Let's go!
Now I'm playing.
I was just a Lumi.
I hope she lands on your square, Pippa.
That would be the best move ever.
If I land on a Pippa, you're done.
It would be so fucking funny.
You're so lucky.
What is that?
No!
You don't even have money!
That sucks!
Do you want us to bail you out?
That's terrible.
Or you can mortgage your place.
Yeah, you can mortgage.
I need an angel investor to invest in my new company idea.
I'm gonna make FaZe...
Give me one of your properties.
FaZe Grand.
I'm gonna become FaZe Banks.
I'm gonna kick out half of my members.
I'm gonna build a new FaZe.
I'll invest if you give me one of your properties.
Okay, that's something really good.
I'll also invest if you give me one of your properties.
I want your red property.
That's cool.
Any other offers, Your Honor?
I want your electricity.
Okay, cool.
She wants to take my effing bill off of me.
That's fine.
How much are you gonna offer for my electricity?
I'll give you 150.
That's what it's worth.
You're really demanding, Fillion.
For someone that's in debt, you might as well just mortgage.
You might as well just mortgage if you're being very demanding.
Are you the dog?
Yes.
I'm the hat.
Put it on the subreddit.
I'm farming karma off her.
How do I come over to you?
You just hover over to yourself.
Give me your electricity.
How do I request money?
You can... like that.
I'll give you 150.
Okay, great.
So that's good.
Good deal.
That's $20 on top of what you owe me.
You know?
Yeah.
So you're making $20 on this deal.
And then you give her...
I'm saying...
You're taking mine!
You are fucking giving...
Deal or no deal?
You're just giving her back...
She takes back the money, Fillion.
I have a proposal for you.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll take it.
What's the proposal?
No, don't do this to me.
Top of the portfolio.
A little proposal for Dokie.
What is this proposal?
Life is cruel.
I've got this electric company.
Yeah?
I heard it was owned by Fillion.
What happened?
And I will post a picture of you publicly online.
I heard it was owned by Fillion.
How did you get the electrical company?
It is mine!
Dokie is the owner.
That's so interesting.
I own 49%.
I put in this deal.
I told you the mortgage, Fillion.
I only trade at 51%.
It's my turn to go to the store.
You get to throw another dice.
How lucky are you?
I'm going to throw something else.
Watch boardwalk.
Double dice.
Oh, you're so...
You're going to watch this chat.
This is called the luck of the Irish.
This is called the heart of the cards.
Check me out, boys.
Oh, you get content.
You got beauty content.
You're so beautiful, Fillion.
Nice dodge.
Check my Twitter for the face reveal.
You should try Limbo next time you're streaming.
So we can see how good a dodging you are.
I am pretty good.
Check me out.
Watch this.
You can roll again, by the way.
Roll again.
Oh, my god.
She's dodging.
She's dodging right now.
If she hits the fucking...
Does she get the...
It would be so funny if she can't...
What did I get?
What?
Thanks for boardwalk.
Thanks for getting me this again.
I really appreciate it.
Okay.
How are you feeling, Fillion?
How are you feeling?
I'm the elbow of every joke right now.
To be fair, you did...
You sort of set yourself up.
To be fair.
You probably would be your mom.
All I'm saying is that you...
You demanded a lot.
Very early game.
You gotta play the game.
You went in with full ego there.
You know what?
Your skin don't fit.
And your mother never loved you.
I feel like somebody's projecting right now.
Are you projecting?
Hey, look.
My railroad.
I always land on my railroad.
He always land on my own railroad.
All right, Pippa.
You can do it.
I don't wanna get out.
Maybe...
It's all to God.
It's fierce out there.
The outside world is scary, guys.
It's safer in jail sometimes.
Yeah, it is pretty safe over there.
I should head to jail.
All right.
Can I get a...
Oh, thank God.
What is this?
Why not land on my property?
I would have felt so fucking bad.
Oh, shit.
You have to pay each of us 50.
You have to come back.
You've been elected chairman.
I don't wanna leave.
I got you out of jail, Pippa.
You can come back now.
You can come back.
It's my turn to pass this.
It's cozier in there.
I'm hosting the bingo night.
It's for a bunch of charity.
It's for tax relief.
Where is this?
Seven's the most common number you can want, guys.
And I'm also gonna pay you.
It's your own place.
You're safe.
I know.
I own this property.
You can also put more property there.
This is what the founding fathers intended.
Yeah.
Just press shift.
You can make it $30.
Shift again.
She has to even out the houses.
Yeah.
You have to even out the houses.
Nice!
90 bucks!
Now you have 100!
Yeah!
Good for you!
Wait, how many properties do I own?
I own one extra one.
It's fine.
You own four.
How do I... help me out?
Get me out.
Okay.
I feel like I might last.
Oh, thank god!
As long as it's not Pitbull's place.
That place is scary.
You're in a row of haunted houses.
Yeah, this is...
I'm fine with that.
Alright, alright.
This is an alliance, man.
Yeah, this is an alliance.
We owe each other.
You know what?
I can afford...
Do I afford it?
Can you buy a house on Kentucky Avenue?
Let's see if I have the same set.
You know what?
Fuck it.
Let's do it.
I'm playing a little dangerously right now.
Alright.
Enter.
We're ashamed you landed there.
Hi, Pippa.
Are you enjoying your jail time?
Pippa holds up for your tax crimes.
Oh, nice!
Nice!
I have a library card in here.
Oh my god!
They're teaching her how to use a computer at the moment.
When you get out, teach me how to make moonshine.
You can become a jail lawyer!
A jail lawyer?
Yeah!
You can actually be... I learned that orange is the new black.
You can become a lawyer in jail.
Is this the last pink?
Oh, that's the last pink!
Pippa, you're a coward!
What?
Me?
Wow, she insulted...
She was about to offer you something, and then you insulted her.
I don't think she's gonna offer you anything.
I said that to Pippa, not Lumi.
Wait, no.
Yeah.
What's your deal?
Oh, Lumi.
I have a deal for you.
300.
For the pink.
She doesn't have 300.
She's got a mortgage.
Yeah, she'll get there.
You gotta sell your houses.
Wait, you're gonna give me the second out of three properties for $300?
$300.
Are you thinking I'm a brainlet?
Do you think I eat tower one for breakfast cereal?
I mean...
What in the hell am I gonna do with a second property?
When I can't even pay rent on my own life!
$300?
How will you take those and...
I heard that VTubers aren't the best with financial planning.
So you know...
You'll never have the inkling.
If you ever have an inkling, you'll have to get a new one.
What's this?
Let me know.
Oh, is that my train station?
That's my railroad.
Nice railroad.
You're in debt.
Okay, it'll be $300.
What do you say?
I can give you...
I can give you $80.
$80 for the thing.
What happened to $300?
Yeah, well, now you're kind of in a disadvantageous situation.
We are in the deal.
What happened to $300?
Fillion, just mortgaged your house!
I am the only one who can bail you out, Fillion.
I'm the only one who can bail you out, Fillion.
Wait, can I sell a house?
Fillion, you can literally bail yourself out.
How?
You can bail yourself out!
Go to the board map!
Dude, there's more buttons than train!
Move your cursor around!
Wait, what do I own?
What do I own?
You own the blue shit!
But I also own one more property I don't care about.
How do I sell it?
Go to control!
No, you can't!
Okay, you have to find your... that's my property.
Find your property.
So which one is mine?
God bless you, you're crying.
I don't have to pick one.
One of these is mine.
This one!
There you go, control.
You can't sell it.
You have to mortgage it.
Oh, wait, that's...
No!
Fillion, you don't have options!
No, I do!
You either mortgage or you make a deal.
You have another IOU.
Fillion, that won't even be enough for you.
You need $80.
You can mortgage two properties.
Please, dude.
Like, come on, man.
You were gonna mortgage it anyway.
We better a lot!
You're gonna lose the game.
You're gonna get $70 if you mortgage it.
You can sell your houses.
I'll give you $100.
Thank you.
That's a good-effing deal.
You can sell your houses, though.
Just so you know.
I like moving.
Oh my god.
Lomi, you gotta start leveraging tweets and stuff.
You gotta tweet that Panic!
Lomi is the fucking best.
All I'm saying, Lomi, is that you could've asked.
She's like on her knees right now.
Do you stream on Twitch?
Fillion's willing to do anything right now, Lomi.
You should've asked for more.
Stream on Twitch, deal?
Alright, I accept.
Alright, I'll take it.
What are you doing?
You so don't.
She actually scammed you.
Wait, I didn't give you the money.
Wait, Sarah, I didn't give you the money.
I didn't hit okay.
You hit my owner.
You lost.
I gave you.
And she took it.
All I'm saying is...
I'll give you $110 for your show.
There you go.
You didn't notice this, but she took one of your properties too, Fillion.
I know that.
She literally took it.
She literally took your property.
We were trading my property.
Kick her while she's down.
Lomi, leverage something.
Do it.
How do I take more from her?
Good.
How do you accept the deal?
Just press deal.
Lomi, you coward.
You could've gotten more.
She's desperate.
She didn't even notice that you took her property.
She didn't even notice.
She's stealing the property for the money, dog.
That was the entire point of the match.
I kind of earned money from this one.
Now we know that Fillion doesn't look at what she's trading.
I'm surely in virtual reality and there's four people that could steal my money every time I make an epic deal.
Is this stealing if you don't even pay attention?
It's definitely stealing.
You might have a friend, okay?
Trick.
My turn.
See, in the spirit of fairness, I need to have someone to exploit if we're gonna keep playing this game.
I'm gonna pay four dollars.
Am I getting taxed again?
Oh, no, I didn't.
Okay, thank god.
I was gonna say that.
I can pay.
Yeah, I can pay four dollars.
It's just four dollars.
What's four dollars between four and a doggy?
Exactly.
Yeah, see?
Let's see.
Oh, I can buy more props.
Okay, I'm gonna put it on...
Can you put a house on me?
Put it on Blue.
Can you Wizard Boss me?
You guys hear something?
I can't hear people who have income less than fifty dollars.
Yeah.
Can I take a header?
That's the quiet point that I hear right now.
I'm rich death right now.
Okay, I'm starting OnlyFans.
Yeah, people!
No!
Oh, no, you're out.
You're out.
Yeah, people!
Shut up, Billy.
You landed on a chance.
Yeah, you landed on a chance to land on an Indiana.
You're lucky.
Let's go!
Oh, you gotta go to my place.
Wait, you have to go to my place?
Wait, what?
How did you get here?
I didn't even pass gold.
Isn't this where you literally are?
Wait, how did you get to my place?
Want me?
How much do you need?
Give me a dollar.
I'll bill you up.
I'm all in, chat.
I'm all in on blue.
I like how nobody's mortgaging.
What's mortgage?
I'm a woman.
I don't know what that means, man.
It's when you get engaged.
What do you mean women aren't real?
I have no idea what mortgaging is.
It's when you get engaged.
Oh!
Yeah, if you marry the dude from Rick and Morty, well, A, you get an effing lawsuit, but B, you get mortgaged.
My money's all going to Doki.
Oh, it's going back to me, right?
Oh shit, yeah, it's going back to me!
Yay!
Congrats, Doki!
I want to go to jail too.
I feel safer in jail now.
I'll give you my pay.
I'll give you my pink if you give me the electricity.
Okay, Doki, Doki, Doki, do you want to marry me?
What?
No, of course not.
Marry me, no prenup.
I can pay this.
Alright.
I'll do a trade.
I'll give you a monopoly if you give me my monopoly.
Uh, yeah, fucking deal.
What the...
Alright, alright.
Poor thing.
I'll give you my monopoly.
Alright, here's your monopoly.
Yay!
And then I'll...
I'll give you this monopoly.
Hell yeah.
You know the song on Terramotors was discovered four days ago and it was found to be in a dumb song called Angel's Thesis?
Alright, I take that deal.
Enjoy your electricity.
I didn't need those anyway.
It's fine.
I want electricity.
Now I own the water and the electricity.
Woo!
Alright, $90.
We are all so fucking poor.
All I'm saying is that Lumi's gonna win the end game because she has three monopolies.
She has three monopolies.
Watch me go.
To infinity and beyond!
We're gonna have a powerful throw.
I can't bail anyone out anymore.
Yeah!
You're gonna land on a doki.
Wait, you land on a doki?
We're gonna have a powerful throw.
$200.
All I'm saying is that you need a mortgage.
Nobody's bailing you out.
You wanna do this to me, Lumi?
I can't!
I don't have shit, man!
Doki, Doki, Doki, Doki.
Marry me, please.
I love you.
Doki, I looked at you and I realized I'm not gay.
Yeah, are you willing to sign a prenup?
Are you willing to sign a prenup?
Okay, no.
But that's the thing.
If it's true love, we should trust you.
Are you willing to sign a prenup then?
If it's true love, you're willing to sign a prenup because you're not in it for the money.
That's what prenups are.
You're not in it for the money.
So you're willing to sign it.
Yeah, I know, but is it really true love if we sign a prenup?
That just sounds like we don't even trust each other.
But if it is true love, then you're not in it for the money.
So you would willingly sign a prenup.
Yeah, I know.
I don't want the money.
Why would we sign something to make it so official and stingy when we could literally just nod and love each other forever?
Wow, you suddenly fell in love with me because you landed on my property?
That's so fucking weird.
I just love how you can go boardwalk.
What can I say?
I love a woman with a boardwalk.
Think about this Doki.
Have you kissed a man before?
Bankrupt yourself.
Bankrupt yourself now.
Probably not.
But if you did, that wouldn't be gay because men kiss women.
Bankrupt yourself now.
You got a mortgage.
I'm not making any deals with you, Fillion.
You did it to yourself.
You did this to yourself.
You're in a special class.
You can't hang out with us anymore.
Yeah, you can't hang out with us anymore.
How are you going to get married?
You can't sit in our table.
No deal.
Wait, wait, wait.
You didn't hear my deal yet.
Okay, what's your deal?
Yeah.
Okay, no deals.
You get married.
Give me all your property.
I'll bail you out.
Women are not property.
I would never.
Give me one of your blue property and I'll bail you out.
I did that.
Or you mortgage it.
Here, Fillion.
You mortgage your property.
You bail yourself out.
You give me your blue property and I bail you out.
That's not what we do.
What?
Can I use up, up, down, down, left, right, circle, square, triangle, star or not?
Or you can bankrupt yourself now.
Just bankrupt.
Just mortgage?
Fillion.
What?
It's over for you, Fillion.
Just mortgage, man.
Just mortgage.
Okay.
How do I even...
Sell your houses.
You can sell your houses.
Oh, I can?
Yeah, you go to your house.
Go to your territory stuff.
You have to sell all of them.
You need $250.
Yeah, but you sell all your houses.
Keep selling.
Keep selling?
You can't even fucking afford it.
And then mortgage.
And then you mortgage.
She still can't afford it.
Yeah, but if she mortgages it, she can afford it.
Fillion, you have to.
You either bankrupt, mortgage, or give me your property.
$70.
Give me your property.
$70 and you owe me a loan.
$70 and get married.
Give me your property.
If you want to get married, give me your property.
I'd rather be a stripper.
Well, it's time to go to the strip club.
Oh, yeah.
You know what you want to do?
I'm going to lose my property now, but I'll regain it later.
See?
I'm going to sell this for $70.
No, you mortgage it.
You don't sell it.
You mortgage it.
Or you give it to me.
And I'll bail you out.
Okay, so I need how much money?
$70?
I need $71.
So you mortgage two buildings.
I sold all my buildings.
No, you mortgage your property.
I know!
But listen!
Nice job.
There you go.
Now you can afford it.
Yes.
Wow.
Welcome to the rich side.
Now pay it all.
You had to pay it all.
Now pay it.
Okay, do you think Spongebob would be good on OnlyFans?
Because I'm looking for a sick combo right now.
Maybe it's time to go back to Fansly.
It's time to head to that pole.
Pipa... no, Pipa...
Wait, what?
It comes off my tongue very easily.
Put a pole in your 3D world.
That works.
Oh, yeah.
Put a pole in your 3D world.
Yeah.
It's my property!
Wait, what is this?
I own electricity!
Electric!
That could have been you, Fillion.
I don't even need $14.
I do like a trillion.
I don't think Donald Trump could save me.
This is fucking terrifying.
I'll put another house here too.
I can afford it now.
Stay away from Illinois.
Chicago isn't worth it.
Alright, nice.
I have houses there.
Entered.
I'm so awesome.
Oh, God.
$6 in a dream, baby.
Let's go.
This is so scary.
Oh, nobody owns that.
What is that?
Is that the chance?
The community box?
Yes, the community chest.
Yeah, you did land on Lumi's place.
You won $100!
Yay!
Nice shots!
Your dog was rich.
Holy shit, she's making it.
Hey, Fillion, how are you feeling?
I like Skittles.
Motherfucker.
I landed on the three houses!
Oh my God!
You landed $800!
$800!
Yo, anyone, any GGers in the chat...
$800 is fucking over.
Nobody... Oh, you have to bill yourself.
Jesus.
Jesus Christ, man.
Jesus fucking Christ.
Yo, bill yourself now.
Wait, I own this, right?
I own this.
Yeah, you own this.
You can bill yourself.
Okay, we can take that off.
Okay, wait, wait.
$800?
I have $38 with your name on them.
Come on.
I can't hear you, Fillion.
No, I'll tell you who I am.
I'm saying Pippa's gonna be secretly rich.
Lumi, I have $38 with your name on them.
I literally have $38.
I really can't... I have to mortgage it.
Fuck!
Let's do a deal, Lumi!
You have to mortgage everything.
I don't think you can, Lumi Let's do a deal.
Jesus...
I don't think you can afford anything.
I don't think I can do this.
I'm gonna make sure someone bankrupts it.
I think you have to like, okay mortgage everything and see what happens...
$500.
This is $80.
$150.
Fillion, you have nothing.
She can't do anything with your money.
$800.
She owes 800!
You're leveraging things you know that have.
I can 10x you in months!
How could you?
I can 10x you!
I'm gonna sell...
I'm not gonna sell the orange.
I'm gonna sell the...
shit.
Anyone want this shitty brown one?
I need my last dollar, chat.
God, what do I do?
What's the point of three monopolies when you can't fucking sell shit?
I'm selling... okay.
Try mortgaging everything so you can afford it because it's 800 fucking dollars.
800?
Fuck you, man.
This is fucked up.
I don't think... can you make it?
I mean, you have a lot of property.
Four dollar, nipple woman.
I need a bailout.
I need a fucking bailout.
Four dollar, nipple woman.
I can bail you out the remaining, I think.
I'm gonna sell the...
I'll give you two of my oranges.
Alright.
For 300.
Yeah, I'll take it.
305, because that's 800 exact.
I'll give you two of the more expensive ones.
How about that?
Alright.
I'll give you these two.
I'll take it.
That way you won't even land on it.
How rich...
How rich?
More than 50 dollars.
Oh my god.
Can I be in the cool kids club?
I can't.
I have a thousand dollars in my bank account that I'm not accessing.
It goes to a different school.
Do you?
I do.
You can't just raise money for being poor.
Yeah, I mean we're all fucking poor now.
That's how Monopoly works.
305, that's all I need.
Okay, I'll trade you for food stamps.
Come on, man.
I'll just let you for a week.
She's so high.
She's so bankrupt.
Two oranges.
What do you mean?
Holy shit.
I'm gonna have a dinosaur this week.
Please, man.
How many times did I bail you out?
Oh my god.
It's exactly zero.
This is fucked up.
Oh my god.
You know, a billion has a chance to land on Pippa Square too.
Wait, if I land on Pippa Square, I'm fucking out.
If you land on Pippa Square, you're fucking out.
If I land on Pippa Square, I'm out.
Just let me be in jail.
Let me be in jail.
Boardwalk!
What do you mean boardwalk?
Yeah, I own boardwalk.
I'm free!
Yes!
No, but you have to pay Lumi.
Thank you.
You don't even have $52.
You gotta boardcast your last property.
Pippa Square.
Pippa!
I love you.
I'll give you the money.
Wait, what?
Do you wanna get married?
No.
And you have to make a tweet.
You have to make a tweet.
You add Lumi, me, and Dokibird.
And you fill up the rest of the character limit with how great we are.
Okay.
But you have to put our ads at the end.
So that it'll show up on your Twitter feed.
And then put the ads on it.
Okay, give me one second.
But you have to post a tweet in our Discord group.
And then so we can approve it.
And make edits if we need to.
And Sam, you can tweet it out.
Okay, okay, okay.
Give me one second.
Pippa, how much are you gonna give me?
And you have to pin the tweet.
For at least a week.
I don't wanna pin it.
A hundred bucks is so worth.
And you have to pin it for at least a week.
So you're saying your dignity is worth a billion?
Yeah, yeah.
You hear that chat?
One akasupa is worth one billion.
I would never eat a tomato.
Alex Jones.
I love blonde people.
At Pippa.
Wait, no, I should do Dokibird.
Pippa first, of course.
Right, Pippa?
Pippa first.
At Pippa, at Dokibird.
Okay, at... what's the name of his Twitter?
What's the name of his Twitter?
I'm gonna tag him in Austin Gaming.
Alright.
I would die on a sword for you.
Guys, I would give you my brain transplant.
Parenthesis.
With your consent.
I am nothing but a simp on the track.
Ka-chow.
Lightning.
All I'm saying is that there's apparently a timer.
So like, if you run out of time, you don't even get this deal.
I'm putting it in the group DM.
You gotta type the right ad, man.
What is your ad?
No deal.
This is exactly why I had her write it in our group chat first before she tweets it out.
Are you Lumi Kaneko or what?
What is your name on Twitter, dawg?
I think it's Kaneko underscore Lumi.
I think.
Kaneko underscore Lumi.
Just copy it in.
Edit your tweet.
Okay.
You got this.
I'll post it again.
Alright, alright.
There you go.
And then you gotta make sure that you pin that tweet for at least a week.
Yeah, pin it.
A week?
That's how much a hundred dollars...
That's your worth.
Is that not your worth, Billion?
Bro, it's like Animal Farm.
Or you go bankrupt now.
You go bankrupt now.
I'm tweeting, I'm tweeting, I'm tweeting.
You can't be serious, dude.
Oh my god.
Is this what you want?
Is this what you want from me?
Alright, Billion.
Is this...
Just press enter.
We're waiting for you to accept the deal.
I want you guys to say sorry.
Why?
What do we do?
It's just business.
She bailed you out.
Yeah, she bailed you out.
You gotta say thank you to Pippa.
You got 300 likes.
Thank you, Pippa, for bailing me out.
I'm so...
My life is in your debt, Pippa.
You gotta say that to her.
She literally bailed you out.
She noticed.
I was hoping you would notice.
You didn't fucking see it.
Stitch!
You're gonna make me embarrass myself like an effing rich person playing Squid Game and then when I'm effing done you're gonna trim my armor?
Who do you think I am?
Someone must have ratted out in her chat.
There's no way she noticed it herself.
I learned from my mistakes.
How do I take this junk out?
I don't even know what it is.
How do you take this junk out?
You press enter.
Yeah.
You press space and enter.
Oh, wait.
Oh my god!
Billion!
Thank you!
Pippa!
Trim my property back.
I'm gonna delete the tweet.
Trim me it back or I delete the tweet.
If you delete the tweet, I'll never bail you out again.
I'll never bail you out again.
No, no!
Give me my property back!
I will never bail you out.
No, my honor is with you.
It has 1,000 likes in one minute.
Please, please.
I'm getting mauled on Twitter.
I'm gonna play.
Trim me.
Any publicity is good publicity.
No, no.
I don't want any tweet ever.
No, I'm gonna delete the tweet.
Please, please, Pippa.
Please.
Pippa, you literally have an advantage over her.
She's like banking on her knees.
You can ask for anything from her now.
Pippa, give me my property back.
I'm not kidding.
I'm not kidding, Fillian.
Yeah, the adults are talking.
I'm gonna delete the tweet.
What do you think?
You gotta ask her to do something embarrassing now.
I'm gonna delete the tweet.
If you delete the tweet, we're never bailing you out on Monopoly.
I'd rather die than not send a tweet.
I'm not gonna go out on a skim.
I'm not going on a skim.
So, you'd rather be the first one to lose in Monopoly?
Yes.
That's what you'd rather be the loser in Monopoly?
See?
The first one to lose.
Okay, you know what?
Frick you.
Maybe I don't.
Four of us.
You would want to be the first in that group.
Okay, just talk.
Talk.
Just effing talk.
It's at 1,500 likes.
Thanks, guys.
At the VTuber Awards, can you say you're the loser at Monopoly?
Oh, my bad.
Sorry.
It's at 2,000 likes.
I lied.
At the next VTuber Awards, just say Fillion, the loser at Monopoly.
Yeah, and we'll bail you out.
We'll trade you.
Pippa, we'll trade you back to property if at the VTuber Awards, you say I am bad at Monopoly.
Yeah.
At the VTuber Awards, you have to be like, I'm terrible at Monopoly.
And we will trade the...
Pippa will trade back to territory.
No, I want something I can do right now.
No, we will have an IOU.
We'll just have an IOU for the VTuber Awards.
Give me something I can do right now.
What's the most embarrassing thing you can possibly do?
Probably delete a tweet.
No.
Make the tweet your banner.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, true.
You would do this to me?
Make the tweet your Twitter banner.
And your YouTube channel banner.
Because it has 2 million subscribers.
Pippa, she has more subscribers.
She has more people on her YouTube channel than her Twitter.
So she should make it a banner on her YouTube channel.
No, no, no, no.
YouTube banner.
You get the territory back.
You get your property back.
I'll just lose Monopoly.
That's fine.
Just lose Monopoly.
I'll delete the whole of your tweet.
You'd rather lose Monopoly.
It's billion.
It's such a small thing.
I'm going to end stream on the radio.
It's just a small thing.
Billion.
Why are you letting Monopoly get to you?
Just make it my Twitter banner.
Because at least it can take the plate on one platform.
On the Twitter banner?
Okay, nice.
Alright, sure.
Now I just negotiate myself backwards.
You know how negotiating works?
You give a long, tall order.
So they'll want you to do...
I'm not winning Monopoly.
You didn't want us to do this.
What the hell is this?
Okay, whatever.
That's how negotiating works.
You give a very big demand.
And then it'll make them want to do the louder demand.
Because you weren't going to do the Twitter thing at first.
Alright, banner.
Alright, Twitter banner now.
I am!
Part of the deal, baby.
Ah, na-na-na-na-na-na-na.
Okay.
Edit profile.
Change my effing banner.
Downwards.
This is so dumb.
The best trade trailer there used to be.
If you call my Twitter, it'll be the same.
I did it!
Bro, we're getting an ad space.
I'm putting my profile finger stuck in the middle of my face.
Alright.
Are we done?
Yep.
Just pay for it at $52 so we can trade.
Hit the pay.
Give me my money.
Please, give me my property back.
Press on!
Okay, you do it for me.
I don't want to do this.
Oh my god.
Yes.
Okay.
Now, and then you have to ask for...
Give a little bit of money.
Okay, I'll give a dollar.
Okay.
Alright.
There you go.
Hit... no, it's not.
Hit enter!
I'm deleting the tweet!
No!
No, no, you...
You said a week.
I did that, but now guess what?
Who's gonna stop me now?
Who's gonna stop me?
What is it?
A fussy baby.
We were making business negotiations.
I know!
You don't get to talk while the other guys are talking.
You should've talked to me.
I'm gonna go to the kids table, Fillion.
I'm gonna go to preschool all over again.
This is Fillion and her fucking zoo pals place.
My face is so familiar with the inside of a toilet from the number of straws I've gotten.
Please stop being like that.
Yeah, I own this property!
Jesus.
No honor.
No honor, man.
I think Pippa's gonna win this in the end.
Her property is scary.
I don't know.
It's Bettina!
Oh my god, boardwalk!
Hey, $50!
Oh, that's mine?
That's mine?
Yeah, that's the money!
Hey, Fillion, remember when you landed on boardwalk?
Yeah, remember that?
That was so funny.
That's the place you boys wanted.
I could've been paying you $50.
Can I get in jail, please?
Yeah, I wanna go to jail.
I want jail.
Give me jail.
I don't wanna be here anymore.
Oh, you got that!
Oh, you got afforded!
Jesus!
But Pippa can.
I'm just fucking withdrawing.
Enjoy your property.
I don't know what you expect, Fillion.
We didn't win $1!
You have to withdraw.
Please.
$121.
This is horrifying.
This whole game is fucked up.
I'll enter.
Just let me fast go.
Okay.
We're at the stage where it's like it's the final countdown.
And everyone's gonna get bankrupt first.
Wait for death.
You have to pay $100.
You don't have money, but...
You don't have...
I love your...
What tweet do you guys want?
Just mortgage.
You have one more property to mortgage.
I know.
I can tweet too.
Well, we know you're gonna delete the tweet.
This is how you get addicted to drugs, no?
It's like, yeah, don't worry.
I can just sell off a body part.
Just give me a little...
One hit.
The thing is we can't trust you anymore because you said you delete tweets.
So we can't trust you about tweets anymore.
I'm not my mama.
I'm not mama.
You are making me kick...
You are evicting me from my home.
Just so you know.
We are evicting a VTuber.
Your arrogance did this.
Yeah, your arrogance did this.
My arrogance?
What do you mean?
Biblically accurate Elden Ring characters?
What?
The price of your own arrogance, Millian.
Oh, how she's fallen.
Okay, like what is this?
You don't even pay it to like us.
Yeah, you pay it to like the government.
The government.
I am not a fan of the government.
I'm not a fan of the government.
I think I might have to mortgage soon.
I don't think I'm gonna survive.
Pippa is fucking scary.
Apparently the FaZe next CEO saw my tweet.
Okay.
Yeah, he's laughing at you.
That's great.
Okay.
Yo, can I join FaZe?
Oh hey, another Ghetto Jeffery card.
Nice.
Now Saginaw, can he bail me out?
Saginaw, I need a bailout.
Yo Fish, if I join FaZe Connect, can you give me a thousand bucks?
You bail her out.
Millian, I'll give you 500.
500, you join FaZe.
Yeah, I'm going Corpo.
Alright, like...
How much?
You give me 500 if I join?
Okay, sweet.
I'm in.
I'll join, and then we won't sign a prenup.
What?
Why would you sign a prenup for FaZe Clan?
Wait, okay, so be honest.
Do you have independence or not?
Independence?
Like, what do you mean?
Can you make a pen dance?
What?
Do you have independence?
Pineapple pen?
Pippa, Pippa, I'll give you a Ghetto Jeffery card for the last blue.
Sounds good.
Let's do it.
This is fucked up, man.
This is fucked up.
Can you even trade the get out of jail free card?
Yeah, you can.
Yeah.
The future is now, old man.
And then I will take the blue.
Wait, Pippa, why would you...
Don't you want to be in jail?
She can pretend she can get out, but she wouldn't.
It's a choice.
She doesn't have to use it.
Pippa, you think this is gonna get you somewhere?
Who's using you, Pippa?
I'm business around here.
What do you mean?
You don't even deserve to be on my board right now.
Oh my god.
It's your fault I'm broke.
My fault?
The corruption is insane, man.
You made your bed, Fillion.
VTuber doesn't take responsibility.
I never will.
My bed bugs pay rent.
Yeah.
Doesn't look like it.
She got us in jail.
Oh my god.
She got the best card.
Hey, Pippa.
Why don't you use it to get out of jail, Pippa?
Why don't you get out of jail, Pippa?
Come on.
Do it.
I mean, I can with the card I just got that you made fun of me for getting.
You're gonna.
I know you are.
You want to get out of jail.
I know you do.
Please let me out of jail.
Let me in jail.
I'm gonna hate this game.
Oh my god.
Yeah.
He got taxed.
No, I see it.
I'm so fucked up.
Oh my god.
Loomy is stealing from the self-checkout.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's what you get.
I put those gummy bears in my pockets so what?
Oh my god.
I'm not allowed to live.
What is that?
That's eight.
That's a lot of numbers.
Oh, hey, it's your own property.
You got saved.
No, no, she mortgaged it, didn't she?
Yeah, she mortgaged it.
But she can't do anything with it.
Can't do it.
No, I can buy a house.
I mean, you can, yeah.
Wait, what does mortgaging do again?
The other spaces, you don't pay anything on the other spaces.
Oh.
If we pay our other two squares that she mortgaged, then we don't have to pay her anything.
Okay, so I have a spot again.
I have a spot again.
No, you don't because you're still mortgaging that spot.
Well, I bought it.
I just bought it back.
I own a mortgage.
You don't.
Oh my god, $50.
My only property is a new sauna.
$50 is better than $800.
I'll take it.
As long as we have a new pipa.
I own a property.
I'm not a property owner.
Dude, I'm one of the elites.
So guys, do you want to get pizza this Saturday?
Yeah.
Do you guys want to have a pizza party?
Pizza party?
We want money.
I have a house.
We can crash at my place.
Can you afford pizza right now?
No.
The pizza hut, they told me I would have burned.
Scavenging from the table.
Yeah.
It's like this.
You know what?
Your website won.
Hey, pipa.
Nice to see you.
Good to see you too.
Learning to be a lawyer.
Yeah.
Gonna be a jail lawyer.
How do you do?
Blue, who's blue?
Oh no.
It's fine.
It's like $5.
It's okay, it's a mortgage.
Yeah, it's mortgage so you're fine.
You got saved.
Can I borrow from you?
No.
You actually got saved.
I think Lumi can un-mortgage this soon.
I think I can if I get close.
Wait, can I un-mortgage my property if I have the money?
You can if you have the money, yeah.
Why am I doing that then?
Well, I don't fucking know.
That's your choice.
I never want something like that.
You know what?
I'll buy it.
What's the proposal?
This little property called Bump the Cabin.
Alright, what's the proposal?
I'll give it to you for $80.
For $80?
I'll take it.
$80?
Does anyone wanna go on a walk?
It's free.
We can steal a dog from the park.
The low low price is $80.
$80.
I will give you a full monopoly.
I'll take it.
That sounds like a good deal.
Wait, that's mine.
Wait, is that?
No, that's right.
Alright, here we go.
Nice deal.
$80.
I'm just struggling to live, okay?
After people bankrupted me.
What am I doing?
I'm just trying to watch you right now, bro.
Look at this bitch!
And now she's hiding in jail.
That's what the mafiosos do.
That's how the rich survive.
She doesn't have to pay taxes because she's in jail.
Yeah, she doesn't have to do shit.
She just sits in jail and chills.
Legally, I have no income.
You're AFK!
You're having AFK!
I hate this game.
I wanna be in jail.
You chose it.
You did choose it.
You did.
You get to have your...
You just have to look through your properties.
You guys made me tweet about it.
Nice.
Alright, end turn.
Does that mean Fillion's gonna pay me?
No, she has to land on it again.
No, it's not my turn.
No, it is your turn.
What do you mean, Fillion?
Roll a two, Fillion.
Roll a two.
I wanna come and hit her.
It's my property.
What is that?
Stop!
You can't even afford...
Guys, it's time to mortgage again.
It's time to mortgage.
Okay, that's fine.
I'll mortgage.
Get back and then...
board.
Okay, that's fine.
She can't even afford it with a mortgage.
Can I...
Can anyone...
You just need like...
I have a gun.
I want to trade.
You want to trade with Pippa?
You only need $58.
Who wants to trade me?
What's $58 worth to you, Fillion?
God, at least one kidney.
Maybe even a contact bar?
Give us one of your blues.
Okay.
Alright.
That's fine.
Oh my god.
Pippa, take it.
Take the blue.
Take one of the blue.
We could sell some feet pics right now on the internet.
Okay.
Wait, does she have a blue?
Yeah.
Take one of her light blue so she doesn't have her monopoly anymore.
She's that desperate.
I don't need to do that to me.
I'm literally that big.
You said okay.
You were taken away from me.
You literally said okay.
Why is Amazon trying to mug her?
You know what?
I'll trade with you.
I'll trade with you for that blue property.
No.
Pippa.
$6 for content reasons.
What?
Content reasons.
I'm mainstream.
Please.
I come to you a humble traveler.
Uh huh.
How humble?
I'll give you a dollar.
Denigrate yourself.
I will give you a dollar.
You will give me...
At least...
$3.
You can't afford the...
I was gonna say not $3.
And now we can be best friends forever.
Final law.
Uh huh.
Final offer.
Take your blues.
How do I add the money?
How do I...here?
There it is.
Deal.
I'm supposed to give you...
Pippa.
You know, we've been through a lot back in our day.
I just wanted to say...
Your hair is so effing nice.
Some days I dream about a white Christmas.
Where I...
I...
Uh huh.
Oh, I'm lagging.
Pippa, how about this?
I'll impress you.
Sticking out your gut for the Rizlan.
I'm not impressed.
You have to ask for two properties because she did that.
I'm trying.
I'll sweeten the deal a bit.
Bro, you messed with her.
You just declared bankruptcy, Fillion.
This is not worth it.
You just declared bankruptcy.
You practically lost everything.
You don't even have anything anymore after you do this deal.
Fillion, think of your dignity, Fillion.
Fillion, just declare bankruptcy.
You basically lose.
Fillion, it's good content.
Alright, give me everything you own.
It's good content.
Think of it this way.
If you declare...
Oh my god.
The mortgage was only $66.
That's so sad.
Holy shit.
Thank you, Fillion.
I think Pippa's gonna win.
There's no way.
There's no way she loses.
Was it worth it, Fillion?
No.
She's practically homeless.
You guys are the same way.
It's like I'm talking to a pack of flamingos.
Bro, Fillion's just homeless now.
She owns nothing.
That's actually crazy.
Fillion, can we still have pizza at your house?
Yeah, what house?
Bro, my house is closed for renovations.
It's closed.
We're renovating it.
Yeah?
Yeah, I'm not going for you.
Yay, they got it.
Got mortgaged.
Holy shit.
I wanna go home!
You don't have one.
Oh.
Dad!
Let's see.
Bro, I'm deflated.
That whole avenue is fucked up.
I know.
That whole side of the board.
It's like over the fucking land on there, man.
Holy shit.
That whole side is scary.
I fucking hate that.
That's a shit.
I wish I was in jail too.
You just jailed me in jail, bro.
I wish I was in jail.
Oh, wow.
You just gained money.
No, you have to pay 50 now.
Yeah, or you used to get a free jail card.
Betrayed dog.
Alright, alright.
Nice, nice.
Thanks, people.
Thank you.
This is $14.
Remember when I like, hoped and dreamed in a family and children and prospects and like, I'm like at least $16 in my bank account.
Yeah, no, it's not $16.
You have $241.
Look at that thing.
Wait, with this money, I summon a victory.
In like 10 minutes.
Yeah, when the property is still around.
I don't think...
Okay, does anyone wanna...
Fuck.
Okay, I'm gonna eat this.
At least it's not...
Hey, Doki, you want a monopoly?
Hell yeah.
I'll get that monopoly.
I can win this chat.
I can win this.
Okay, okay.
Hey, Doki, I've got this one property.
I'm gonna make a limited skin.
Yeah, I'll take it.
50 and then I'll bail you out.
Don't worry, I got you.
How much do you need?
I think I need 140.
140.
Alright, I'll bail you out.
Is this how a monopoly usually rolls at the end?
Do you guys want a burger or the McNuggets?
You know what?
I'll give you 145.
Cause I feel generous.
I'll take it.
She's so generous.
She's literally so fucking generous.
Alright, enjoy your monopoly.
Yay!
Just end stream.
Alright, Jen.
Just fucking give up, man.
I get my money back.
So I got it for free.
It's not over until I actually lose.
Can I go to jail, please?
I actually got the orange for free.
Holy shit.
Can I go to jail, please?
It's not over until I actually lose, chat.
Watch.
Jail me.
I've done so many crimes.
I'm a bad person.
I deserve it.
What is that?
Oh, that's mine.
That's my water.
Oh, that's not a cup.
It's only 40.
What if I just don't shower?
Wait, if both utilities are owned, rent is 10 times the amount shown on the dice.
Oh!
Not bad, not bad.
What if I just don't shower?
Not bad.
Doki, Doki, Doki, Doki.
I'm literally on my last effing...
You're not even using...
You need water.
You have $240.
Yeah, you have $240.
You're still alive.
I can hear her, like, text a speech in the background.
Did you hear that?
Did you guys hear that?
Shut up.
You can't get your chat to bail you out, Philly.
Yeah, your chat can't bail you out, man.
Chat, this is so sad.
Can we get, like, five subs?
Oh my god.
Yeah, five subs at TokiBird on Twitch.
How am I gonna get reduced to a simp?
I just give money to pay people as I walk around.
I'm a little pay pig!
Oink, oink, oink, oink, oink, oink.
Can you put that on YouTube next time you need a bailout?
Just oink, oink a little bit?
Yeah, just oink her chat.
I'm sorry.
I'm just getting sober.
You know, I'm gonna go put a hat on.
Oink, oink, oink, oink, oink, oink.
Where's Philly?
Where is she?
Oink.
There she is.
Okay, what is her closest property right now?
Let's see.
I'm gonna put a house here too.
Put it on boardwalk!
Yeah, I'll put it on boardwalk.
I'll put it on boardwalk for you.
Chad, that's my final destination.
I'm gonna go to boardwalk, I'm gonna buy a room, and then I'm gonna effing die.
Are they gonna fine me that six days later?
Make sure you take life insurance.
Okay.
How much does life insurance cost?
Alright, seven.
Oh hey!
Oh my god.
That's mine!
Everything is yours.
Welcome to the hell zone.
Oh my god!
You gotta sell!
I'm seven hundred now!
Thank you!
Philly?
Yes?
Philly, we can make a deal here.
Even if she trades her entire life savings, like she won't...
What?
Oh, you're gonna give me one card back.
Out of the deal, baby.
Out of the deal.
Don't you want your...
Don't insult me.
Yeah, don't you wanna negotiate?
Wait, you are insulting me.
You're taking more than I...
I sold that for like seven bucks.
You can have a house, Philly.
I don't think you're gonna put in a negotiate with me.
I'm not a virgin, you're not, so...
Yeah?
How about I say no?
You don't have anything!
You don't own anything, Philly!
I'm just taking!
Yeah, I know!
But if I own one property that generates eight dollars and will land on it, it's not gonna get me anywhere.
Eight dollars is more than zero.
It's literally more than zero!
I'll let you make a counter offer.
But I'm just done.
How can you counter offer that?
You don't own anything.
No, it's Pippa's turn to counter offer.
I don't think I know the rules of the game!
I don't think so either!
How do I do this?
Here?
There.
I'm thinking more like this.
Exactly!
Whoa, Liz!
Wait, how am I so all for 150?
I refuse.
And then, we're gonna have to do this again.
Whatever.
Philly, you will regret this.
Yeah, but my proof is already in the draft.
You've made an enemy!
I made an enemy!
Shut up!
I have no dollars, I have no property, I have no hoes, my wife led me for Andrew Tate, and my Bugatti got impounded.
I made Beth a tweeter on a street car.
I'm in San Francisco pooping on the floor right now.
Stop laughing!
Add it to the poop map.
Okay.
Put it on the poop map.
That's fillians.
We'll put a little star on it.
It'll be like the Hollywood Walk of Fame except fillians poop.
What?
Oh my god, the board is more free now!
The board is more generous!
You're gonna make it!
Sell your homes, Pippa!
You have to sell!
You don't need the yacht, Pippa!
Sell it!
Just sell until you need $100 and then ask for a fillian for $100.
Pippa, I'll do the deal for $100.
Can you sell her one of her own mortgage properties and then she can't even use it?
That's true!
Sell the blues because she can't even pay back the...
She can't even pay back the mortgage and you sell it!
Sell the blues!
She can't even pay back the fucking mortgages!
She can't have mortgages!
You're so smart!
My god!
Here, fillian.
All of them.
What?
All her money.
She'll take it.
Take all her money.
What?
What is happening?
Fillian, I'm giving you a monopoly.
Yeah, we just want all your money.
I have a monopoly.
What?
I have one dollar.
Yeah, this is so cheap, fillian.
It's so cheap!
What a deal!
It's like a bargain bin deal.
$150.
Fillian, you're literally gonna get back your monopoly.
Just take away one of the cards.
I said $150.
How about $170?
$100... $160.
$160?
That's how you negotiate.
Should I do it?
Yeah, do it.
$320 value.
That's like half the value.
Half off by giving you one free.
All you people.
There it is, chat.
Now we're back, chat.
He can't even take any money.
You have to pay the bank.
You have to pay the bank $6 each.
$6 each.
I don't get it.
But it's not bad.
Here we go.
I was gonna...
I just literally... she gave me more money.
That's $60, that's $55.
Wait a second.
Oh wait, no it's not.
Oh no it's not.
Wait, no, I can sell it.
No, it's already a bargain.
It's over.
But you got your property back, fillian.
Yeah!
Yay!
You got your property back!
Oh my god!
Goodbye, girl.
What?
Jesus.
Jesus fucking Christ.
I'll keep you in the game.
Lumi, I'll keep you in the game, Lumi.
Okay, I'll give you the floor.
You're the real Monopoly man.
Fuck you.
Fuck man.
I'm fucking over.
You need... you need...
I need a fella.
I'll kick you in.
Don't worry.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god.
If Doki maybe lands on Pippa's, maybe it'll work.
Chad, this is how it's accurate.
Thank you.
Here we go.
Don't worry.
I got you.
Got you.
69.
Nice.
Here you go.
I'm fucking sick of this.
I'm gonna cry.
I own a Monopoly.
Oh my god.
Here you go.
Alright.
You know what?
I will...
I'll repay this mortgage.
Jesus, look at her board.
She's got like everything.
Holy shit.
Were you looking for the one one...
You living by the thread with one dollar.
Watch me lose the Pippa now.
Watch now, watch now, watch now.
Please put me in jail.
Yes.
You lose the $1.
Yeah.
Mina.
Does anyone let me sexually assault them?
I mean if you get two...If you get two.
You'll be fine.
If you get two.
Please.
This section is so awesome.
This is over.
No, you're not.
You're still fine.
Yeah, community chest.
Yeah!
Wow,
American healthcare is what's gonna get me in, huh?
American healthcare.
That's what does me in.
I think you just gotta declare bankruptcy.
Or you can sell your... you can...
Well, you already mortgaged it.
So I can bail you out.
You give me all your blues.
I paid $150 for them.
60.
I can bail you out if you give me all your blues.
Or declare bankruptcy now.
If I declare bankruptcy, do I lose?
Yes.
You'll be the first one to lose.
You're telling me the American healthcare is what's gonna get me in.
American healthcare is what's gonna get me in.
Jokey.
I came into Canada to try the mage system instead.
I'm offering you a bailout.
I'm literally giving you a great deal.
Yo, Pippa, you want the $45?
She can't afford to sell you out.
Well, I don't have nothing.
She can't afford it.
You have $41.
Yeah?
So, trade me for $25.
Yeah, what do I get?
And you can take the blue property.
I don't want the blue property.
I have to pay the mortgage.
It's not as funny as you think it is.
Oh my god.
I want all three.
It's no deal.
We'll just lose the game.
You know what?
Frick you!
We'll lose the game.
No deal.
Chill, chill, chill.
Chill.
Okay, okay.
Give me all of it.
Okay.
Switching one right.
How do I... what am I doing?
Are you okay?
Out of my way.
Oh no, her mouse doesn't work all of a sudden.
Oh wow, the moment you had to give me all of it.
There we go.
Just so you know, this is worth more than you are.
Someone's just fucking...
Someone's salty that they're losing in Monopoly.
That's so savage.
Oh, the pain.
You can pay for your health insurance now.
Is that great?
This will pay off all these mortgages.
Yeah.
Now you just have to pay for the healthcare.
Chat, I'm literally one.
It's okay, you're so close to the end.
Yeah, just grab your toaster and you're done.
Yeah, I'm literally one.
And your turn.
It's my turn now.
Come on, Chat.
Yay.
I'm gonna land on like Pippa Square, I feel like.
Oh, unless...
This luck is insane.
Whoa, Chess!
This luck is literally insane.
Hello, take a trip.
I get to go to my own railroad?
What the fuck?
Let's go.
I'm like a protagonist in a history book.
So I'm like a protagonist in a history book.
I'm just happy to be in jail, man.
All I ever wanted was to be in jail.
Wait, is that...
That's...
Oh!
Chat, we're so lucky!
You own this.
You're so safe.
I gotta roll again, though.
Yeah, you gotta roll again.
Where's that?
Oh, shit.
What is that?
I don't know, I'm scared.
Seven?
No one has any money!
Who is that?
Oh, you got chance!
Oh, you're safe!
You're safe!
Thread the needle!
You threaded the needle!
Go back three spaces!
Oh, I can't!
You forgot!
Now you can reach us!
There's nothing I could've done.
Come on, come on, come on!
And you get money!
At least I'm not Fillion.
She's still in this.
I was in jail for one turn, dude.
I was in jail for one turn.
Alright, alright, alright.
Roll the fucking dice.
Let's go.
I think Fillion's coping right now.
She's...
Oh, you got out!
One time you don't want to get out.
And that's the property you sold me.
I'll bail you out!
Don't worry.
I won't make you the last...
What am I even doing anymore, dude?
What am I even doing anymore?
I'll give you my last fucking dollar.
It's no problem.
Bill, you had no problem, bro.
I'm just letting you go.
How much do you need?
I think I need just thirty-five.
Thirty-five.
I'm just a starving Fillion, dude.
Jesus fucking Christ, man.
I'm about to die.
I'm so glad.
Deal!
Lumi, Lumi, can you trade me a dollar?
Please, I just want to buy a Big Mac.
I'll be the bail out of the government and you're the bail out of the government.
You can get the whole club for one dollar.
Mom, I was supposed to be safe in jail.
Fuck my life.
You and your zero dollars.
No!
Okay, so what's safe?
What?
For you, nothing.
Nothing is safe.
I'll leave a six or an eight.
What did I say?
Just chat.
Roll the dice, Fillion.
Roll the fucking dice.
Right.
Heart of the dice.
Heart of the dice, baby.
I believe in you.
Oh, not boardwalk.
That's a good number, right?
Yeah, you just did the same.
Let's go!
Oh my God.
She's safe for another turn.
She's safe again.
Safe for now.
Look at this property.
My heart.
Which is like the closest?
Okay, Fillion is close to here.
I'm buying a water ticket.
Oh my God.
You're gonna build a house on my property.
That's my property.
Your property?
You build a whole city and you have more fans there than I do.
I'm getting more like Drake vs.
Kendrick.
Good luck.
You don't land there.
Listen, listen, listen.
I know how this junk works, okay?
I literally had a house there.
If you land on that, I will owe you like $14.
I don't give a frick.
Pippa!
Pippa, I'll bail you out.
Or you can sell your mortgage your property.
Yeah, mortgage or bail.
It's time to fuck off.
Mortgage or bail.
I'll give you an IOU.
Okay, I'll take it.
I'll take it.
Pippa, please, do the last one in.
Pippa, I have $200.
I can't die before Fillion.
Pippa, come to me.
I have $200.
Yeah, and nothing to offer.
I have a lot of assets.
Yeah.
You have nothing to offer.
This is action 3v1.
I'm just bailing people out.
You know what, brother?
I'm not being torturous.
I'm bailing people out.
I'm being generous.
You're going to bail me out?
You built a house on Blue.
I gave you the option to get bailed out.
You didn't take it.
I gave you that option.
I will get out of your house.
Specifically because I'm going to buy it.
I'm not going to bail you out.
I'm going to bail you out.
You're not being liar.
You rejected it.
I'm in the death zone.
I'm becoming an atheist.
You're fine.
Please, please, please.
You're a Fortnite 2018 great pistol.
Chance, chance, chance.
If unowned...
No dice and pay over.
Ten times?
Yeah, it's me.
Geez.
Goodbye, cool world.
Hey, Nani.
Yeah, I can bail you out.
Don't worry.
I can bail you out.
Just until Fillion dies.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Of course.
Just all I need to live.
All I need to live.
Just gotta live until Fillion dies.
No, chat.
These clubs are real.
How much do you need?
I think I need 90.
90?
Okay, don't worry.
I've got you.
We're independent VTubers.
Don't let these corpos blossom around.
This is money for you, DoseBank.
Stand up for yourself.
All for you.
Come on.
You want my wallet?
Dollars are an endangered species.
A wallet for DoseBank keeps the organ collectors out there.
Exactly.
Don't worry.
I got you guys.
Alright, thank you, thank you.
Alright, so not dead.
Shit!
Oh my god.
Let me go back to jail, please.
This is unbelievable.
Let me end it all.
Doki, independent VTubers strong together.
No, you're kind of mythic.
Boardwalk!
Oh, it might actually be, no?
Oh shit, she's a devil.
She's just missing it.
She avoids it.
She avoids it yet again.
So I'm gonna go to jail for after the walk you up.
Okay, you know what?
I'm gonna go up to the security guard and twerk them.
I'll be a devil and a racist.
That's my plan of action.
She gets to avoid jail yet again.
She's so fucked up.
Oh, is that Pippa's?
No, that's mine.
Oh, thank god, that's mine.
You own everything, Doki.
Oh yeah, I do.
You own the entire side of the board.
Where is she going?
Okay, I'm gonna put a house here.
What are you doing?
Actually, I'm gonna put a house here.
She might land on here more often.
Am I in the Middle East?
Every step is a landmine.
This is ridiculous.
I'm gonna put it here.
And then I'm gonna put one here as well.
And then here as well.
Good luck, good luck, Fillion.
Good luck.
I believe in you, Fillion.
Good luck, Fillion.
Fillion, I believe in you.
It's not my turn.
Hey, you're fine.
Thank you.
Community chest.
Look at that, she's alive.
Run out.
Hey!
You got another bailout.
Look at you.
Making it.
Please let me go to jail.
Please, please, Snake Eyes, Snake Eyes, Snake Eyes.
Come on, Snake Eyes.
Oh, you get a community chest.
Okay, please let me live.
Please let me live.
Yes!
Holy shit.
It's a 4v1.
Good luck, Fillion.
I own this entire side.
So good luck.
I actually got dragged into the military.
So I actually have to go.
Oh, so you're declaring bankruptcy?
You're gonna declare bankruptcy?
Well, you have to leave.
If you have to leave.
See?
Easy.
Oh, hey, that's the one place I just bought the house.
I literally just got bought the house.
That's crazy.
Oh, it's not so bad.
It's not so bad.
I just put one house there.
Look at that.
It's like a rat and it cannot be that bad.
Na na na na na na na na na na na na na.
It's not that bad, see?
Hmm.
She's so happy.
Fillion, you're lying.
Hand an intern for me.
Okay, sure.
She's fucking disabled.
You're taking everything from me.
Might as well take my effing turn.
Oh, definitely.
Let's go.
Might as well take my effing organs.
Yay!
And then I can roll again.
Let's go.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
The luck on this girl is insane.
I think this game would have ended...
Is that mine or yours?
Oh, I get to go to jail?
Oh, that's so unfortunate, guys.
Oh my god.
I get to go to jail.
She deserves that.
She's a good person.
Let her out.
Oh my god.
Can we get a Twitter hashtag?
Her reputation is a bit...
No, it's fine.
I'm fine with being...
It's okay.
You're a criminal.
She's got delicate skin and stuff.
Yeah, yeah.
I got framed, guys.
It's okay.
I got framed.
Look, I haven't...
It was so unfortunate to get framed like that.
Free bird!
How did she owe $20 but I owe $70?
Because I have a house on that property, Fillion.
That's so crazy.
How did that happen?
Fillion, if you've been a nicer person...
Yeah, you've been a nicer person in the beginning of the game.
Am I done?
Oh my god.
It's not over yet.
I'll take that.
I don't care.
It's not Boardwalk.
I'm free.
Alright, Fillion.
Good luck.
I own half of that side as well.
I got this, Fillion.
I'm getting death spell.
That's death row, right?
That's it.
Eight!
Oh, eight.
How many houses is that?
That's like more than one.
Oh.
Fillion, I think it's time.
You don't have anything left.
Fillion?
Wait, you actually don't have anything?
Fillion.
I'm not bailing you out.
There's no bail out here.
Fillion.
What?
It's better on the other side.
Check this board.
Go into the light.
Just accept it, Fillion.
Just end this already.
The rope store is on that street.
Just end it.
I said check this board.
Check this board.
I'll fucking do it.
This is Pippa's choice.
Either we make Fillion lose first now...
or Kira.
Fillion, I'll bail you out.
But you have to give me something.
What does she have?
Not much.
Let's see.
I'm gonna start offering stuff, actually.
Okay, I'll tell you a joke.
No, I don't want a joke.
Your jokes are bad.
What does it mean, you want a brick wall?
Nope.
A brick gets laid first.
Not laughing.
Not funny.
Zoomer humor doesn't work on me.
Next.
Okay.
This game would be ended like an hour ago.
Not gonna lie.
If I didn't do all those bail outs.
True.
All I'm saying is that we could end this game earlier.
I'm the only reason why it's going so slow.
You guys are so dumb.
I'm doing the tweet.
Alright, you're out of the game, Fillion.
Fine.
What else am I gonna do?
Fillion, make the tweet your YouTube banner.
I'll bail you out.
I'm doing this tweet.
Make it your YouTube banner.
I don't know how to do that, Fillion.
You can't lie.
You damn well know.
I don't know how.
You're a liar.
Okay, then you make a YouTube video.
Recording yourself reading the tweet.
What am I effing...
Make it a short too.
Make it a short because she has more viewers.
I'm being sponsored.
Okay.
I'm doing this joke.
The most engagement is her short.
This will be our biggest short ever.
We'll make three dollars on it.
Too late.
I made a decision.
Alright.
Time to bankrupt.
Press the button, Fillion.
Any last offers?
No.
If Lumi even has an offer, she can't afford your bail.
I can't even fucking help you, man.
The only people who can afford it is me and Pippa.
Alright.
You burned the bridges.
Yeah, you burned all your bridges, Fillion.
I knew I shouldn't have been PewDiePie.
What?
Please strike a cat girl while she's down.
It's for an honor, your honor.
I don't know what I'm saying.
So I just hit the button and it's over?
Yeah, it's over.
Unless you want to make that short.
Are you sure you want to make that short?
Yes, come on.
She already deleted the tweet anyway.
True.
It's over.
You're so close to freedom.
I got pretty shot.
And I get to keep that money.
Oh shit.
You took my life for $130 from me.
Let's roll that die.
She just robbed your corpse, Fillion.
How do you feel about that?
It was funny.
Finally, the game can end.
Chat, what's the point?
What's even the point of it all?
You get to draw cards.
I haven't died in a factory on the cold floor.
You didn't have to.
You made your choice.
She didn't even have teeth.
You guys would not have made a YouTube short.
That's on you.
I would have made the short.
I would have made it.
I'm not doing dignity.
It's fine.
Yeah, we'll see when you lose two if you're going to make it.
Alright, I'll pay the $30.
That is sturdy.
Chat, this is why it's hard to make friends on YouTube.
You're welcome.
I'm happy to help a friend of me.
Let's go see your male bonds.
Oh, unbelievable.
Not double as unlucky.
I guess I'll stay in jail a little longer.
I guess I'll stay in jail a little bit longer.
So unfortunate.
Oh, Pippa.
Either I lose to Pippa or Fillion.
That's your own property, so it's fine.
Should we twiddle or...
I'm dead.
I'm dead in a couple turns.
Please, jail.
Please let me have jail time.
You guys made a cult.
I'm muting myself.
I'm going to cry.
Talk to my chat.
I can still hear you.
Yay, money!
Oh, you know what?
I'm going to go build a little bit.
I'm going to...
As long as I'm not last.
Wait, I can build.
Alright.
Let's build a little bit here.
Since I'm in jail, I can still do real estate.
You know?
I can still do real estate while I'm here.
That's the power of the jail system.
Alright, we'll put a house here.
And we'll put a house here.
Good luck, Loony.
Good luck.
And then, I'm ready to roll my die.
Okay.
It just works.
Thanks, Todd.
Thank God.
Doki, how are you?
I guess I gotta pay a fine.
On my own.
Oh, I'm on my own property.
Hey there, guys.
This is so illegal.
Doki owes you a free railroad fare.
I'm hungry, man.
I'm hungry.
Just kill me.
Doki, take me out back.
Shoot me in the fucking head.
You guys are all just surviving right now.
But Lanna got none of it.
Take me out back, man.
Just declare bankruptcy now.
Just declare bankruptcy.
That's all you have to do.
Please, please, please.
Come on.
Free parking, free parking, free parking, free parking.
Free parking.
Where's that?
What is it?
That's me.
That's green.
That's the house I just built.
Goodbye.
You have to have to go.
I don't think I can even...
She cannot afford with mortgage.
She can't afford it even with a mortgage.
I literally can't...
I can't afford anything.
Goodbye, Lumi.
I literally can't fucking afford shit.
It was a good run, boys.
Billy, move over in the cock chair.
I'm coming, okay?
Then you won't even need to be in the cock chair.
Yeah, true, true, true.
It's bankrupt time.
At least I'm in my last place.
Alright.
Leroy Jenkins.
I mean, with all those bailouts, it would be pretty embarrassing being in the... That's crazy.
Wait, Doki just gets my properties?
Yeah, yeah, cause you couldn't pay...
pay off, so I take your property.
Yeah, I wouldn't know.
Ask me anything.
Alright, Pipa, what you got?
Look at that.
There's me.
Uh oh.
Wait, so you don't have everything except Leroy yellow.
Wait, Pipa, use your bonus.
Doki might roll yellow.
I could accident... I could get a...
I could get on yellow and then I'd lose...
Wait, no, I could mortgage.
I could mortgage though.
Yeah, it's not worth much.
She's surviving by like the...
Yeah, four dollars.
For the benefits.
Okay.
Alright, here you go.
I might get the yellow though.
All you gotta do is bankrupt her.
Fuck.
Do I go to jail again?
Pipa, you're the law.
I was like, it's funny if I go to jail again.
Yay!
Pipalism.
Pipalism is this...
Pipa!
Where are you gonna go here?
I can put it on here, on the reds.
I hear boss music.
I'm gonna put one here, here, and here.
Oh wait, no.
I'm on a buttricks.
You have to eventually land here sometime, right?
You only won because you cheated when Pipa DC'd at the start.
I said it.
You know what?
True, yeah.
Okay, to be fair though, each one of us cheated in some way in this Monopoly game.
We live in a society.
What did I cheat?
Oh shit.
I knew Poirot was investing in that one.
I knew I calculated it.
Oh my god.
Perfect calculations.
Oh god.
You can make it to jail.
Jail is so close.
You can still go to jail.
I'm not making it to jail.
You can almost get there.
Wait, $70!
Oh god.
$70!
Oh my god.
You can still land on yellow.
No, I can't.
Yeah, and you can tie your lap around the board later.
It's okay, Pimba.
You got this.
Why?
I don't want you to throw me on.
Oh hey, too hard.
I want you to win.
She just doesn't want me to win.
I don't want to win.
Alright, let's see.
Where are you going to head to next?
Oh, fuck.
She's like an actual murderer.
She's just going to die regardless of you landing on the red here.
You're going to die regardless of you landing on the red here.
I'm going to...
Oh no, not the millionaires.
How many more millionaires must fall?
Those fucking poor millionaires, man.
And how much money do we need, Rich?
I'm with you, Pimba.
Alright, Pimba, you got this.
Come on, grab your pitchfork.
Boardwalks.
Dave Scum.
No!
No, I think that's a seven.
No, that's three rounds.
That's the one that did me in.
Yeah!
You can mortgage.
It might be JoJo.
You can.
You're still at home.
It's all meant for the effect of me getting killed.
No!
Oh, God.
Alright, Pimba, what are you going to do?
What are you going to do?
You have to sell each house.
There's one with three, so you have to sell that.
And then you have to sell...
And then you have to keep selling.
And then you have to sell the other one.
I'm so nervous to watch some...
Oh, Pimba, no!
You're almost there!
One more house.
You can afford it now!
I think it's $750.
Oh, you can't.
Sorry, I lied.
I forgot.
Now you can afford it.
It's been an honor serving with you, Pimba.
She's still alive!
Let's look at you.
You need to get into jail.
Don't worry.
Yay!
Oh my god.
Seven.
Where's that?
Oh, hey, there's chance.
Maybe I can get to jail.
Yeah, I can just click out of the game.
If I just tab out of the game...
Oh, yay!
You get to go in jail!
It's an honor.
Where is she going next?
She doesn't deserve it.
She's been framed, Your Honor.
Let her go!
Where is she going next, though?
She's been framed.
Okay, here we go.
We'll put a green here.
And then also here.
Bro, she's buying houses from jail!
Yay!
She's like the Joker, bro.
I called out to you.
It's rich person jail.
She laughs like the Joker.
Society.
She can lie in jail, too.
Oh, she's one spot away from jail.
Oh, hey, I just bought houses there, too.
What a coincidence.
Did you hear that?
The police are coming.
Goodbye, Pippa.
Wait, mortgage everything.
You can still mortgage everything.
You can mortgage everything.
Yeah, see?
You can afford it now.
Hang on for dear life, Pippa.
Oh!
There you go.
Is that... is that...
Oh, God.
You need to mortgage one more.
This is so grim.
There you go.
I don't think you can afford it.
You need one more.
She's only one more mortgage.
And then she can.
Oh, brother.
There you go.
That last mortgage is looking at you.
You gotta mortgage it.
You can also trade with Doki.
I can't even afford her.
I can't even afford it.
You can't even afford it.
It's not over until it's over.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm in jail.
How could this happen to me?
This is just a training, Pippa.
This is your rocky arc.
Don't worry.
How could I be in jail?
Oh, it's so unfortunate.
I can't even leave jail.
Where is she gonna go next?
Oh, my God.
Boardwalk.
Okay.
Wait, boardwalk!
That's where it all ends.
Okay, okay.
I know you can't afford boardwalks, so I'm just gonna put houses on here.
No, go on boardwalk.
Those are my properties, bro.
We all live down here.
That was your property.
Come hang out with us.
You can fit three on the cock chair.
I'm fighting Lumi and the Gulag right now, Pippa.
Oh, you got saved!
You got saved!
By the luxury tax!
Oh, my God.
Oh, my fucking God.
Wow, I feel good.
You can victory.
You just declared bankruptcy.
You can't lose right now.
You can just give up.
You're so good, Pippa.
Don't worry.
I'm rubbing your shoulders.
You're still in this fight, Pippa.
One more swing.
Don't touch me with your loser hand.
Maybe that's why.
Oh, hey.
That's the one I just put your house on.
It's okay.
It's not worth anything.
Look at that.
It's just $20.
You're good.
Yeah, you're good.
The cockroaches came right there.
I don't have it.
It's okay.
I got a ghetto jail free card.
That's my place, isn't it?
Oh, it is.
Hey there.
Why is this so hard, huh?
It's alright.
She still has like a long way to go.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, for sure.
For sure.
We got this.
I believe in you.
Wait, Pippa.
We need to negotiate.
Part of the deal.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven.
You can afford to have a mortgage.
Yeah.
It would be a shame if you landed on my place again.
It would be such a shame.
It would suck.
Wow.
Hey, you get to visit jail.
I'm the skin of your teeth right now.
Now that Louie's not touching me anymore.
But I'm well.
Oh my god.
You get to visit where I was.
It's like a tourist destination now.
The famous dokey bird was in that jail.
I hate dokey bird.
You can buy souvenirs for like...
$75.
You should mortgage it.
I'm gonna need you to roll too.
You can buy her souvenirs.
Good luck with like two sides of this board.
Wait.
Yeah, it's fine.
You're fine.
Don't worry about it.
You're so fine.
You're fine.
Don't worry about it.
You're gonna be okay, Pippa.
What's the worst that could happen?
You're gonna land on the community chest.
Wait, how much does it cost us?
It's only like $130.
So like it's fine.
It's like...
You're about to mortgage it.
I'm about to mortgage it.
She's calculating right now.
Yeah!
That whole time she gets $20 from me.
That $20 is gonna be so much.
Oh, you're gonna leave!
Goodbye.
He's so mortgaged!
She's so...
Yeah, if you mortgage, you can afford it!
If you mortgage, you can afford it!
If you land on this face, I'm gonna jump.
Thank you.
That was so funny.
Chad, it's not over till the last man sings.
You're still in this.
Till I land on this face, man.
That's your own space, right?
Yeah, see?
It's your own space!
Look at that!
Oh my god.
You're still here.
I think she actually...
No, no, no.
I just missed it.
I landed on my local waterworks.
Oh no!
Come on, Pippa!
You're still in it!
Pippa, you can go to jail if you roll lucky.
Yeah, but she's not lucky.
Damn!
Okay, now it's over.
No.
Now it's over.
Say it ain't so!
Give me all yellow properties.
Give me all your yellow properties.
Stop!
She's already dead, Your Honor!
Your dignity!
Hold your ears up high, Pippa!
Two.
I want all...
I want all your yellows.
Change your YouTube banner, Pippa!
If you wanna keep going, I want all your yellows.
You can't get short!
Make a TikTok, Pippa!
Alright, no.
This is gonna work out.
She's gonna land on all of the luxury taxes.
Alright?
How much do you need?
How much does she need?
How much was it?
Give me a hundred.
Are you kidding me?
Two hundred.
No, it was a hundred.
Not two hundred.
You already told me how much it was.
I told you we could talk about this!
I can't talk about this!
Not even the hundred and ninety-nine?
Are you kidding me?
Accept the deal.
Accept it.
I'm gonna lose my dignity.
Accept.
No!
She bet the deal!
Oh my god.
Are you gonna buy back the mortgage after doing this to her?
I'll pay back the mortgage.
She'll be fine.
Oh my god!
At least let me be close!
Stop!
I'm gonna pay for it.
It's so painful.
Thank you.
It's so painful to watch.
You're still in for it.
You're still in it.
I'm blocking you after this.
I have no property, donkey!
You're gonna stare in your eyes and you'll perish.
Welcome to my house.
Oh no.
It's okay, baby.
You're gonna get go.
You're gonna land on go.
Yeah, I'm...
We're gonna go on the boardwalk.
We're gonna go on the boardwalk!
We're gonna land on the boardwalk!
Boardwalk!
Oh my god!
We actually have a boardwalk!
You have nothing I want.
No!
No deal.
Bankrupt.
We end on boardwalk.
You can make it a spectacle.
It's a beautiful step, Pippa.
Watch the steps.
They're clear of bankruptcy right now.
All the four.
No!
I just wanna say this is Fillion's fault.
He didn't go.
As a prophecy for Todd!
We end on boardwalk!
Chad, I wasn't saying boardwalk when I rolled to get it.
I was saying it because I was predicting where it would end.
That was a callback.
You know what I'm saying?
Oh my god.
Monopoly's pretty easy, guys.
Holy shit.
Yeah, you have a fun time.
Yeah, I actually got a full head start.
Nobody wins with Monopoly.
So, we had a great time, everyone.
I had a great time, guys.
Yeah, we have cucumber sandwiches for refreshments, too.
Help yourself.
Help yourself to my head.
Help yourself to my pride.
Just eat straight away from my head.
Why don't you?
It's okay.
I rehired all you guys to work for me.
Oh.
I wasn't even mean.
Wasn't even mean.
Now you all work for me now.
Yay!
Okay, can we talk about something?
I'm really sorry for flaming you guys.
What?
Oh.
And I want to make a peace offering.
I want to make a peace offering.
Yeah, what is it?
Okay, you guys talk for a minute.
I'll go put it together.
Give me one sec.
A peace offering?
I'm kind of scared.
Me, too.
I'm scared.
What is she going to do?
I'll be back.
Guys, I don't trust her.
I don't trust her either.
Yeah, I don't trust her.
Remember when she rigged the game?
Yeah, remember that?
Yeah, remember when we made a deal and then she deleted the tweet?
She fucking went back.
That's scummy behavior.
Yeah, like the one person that...
I'm going to remember this for the next Vtuber Awards.
Oh yeah.
Adding it to my call out post.
I'm writing the twit longer, Fillion.
Okay.
Don't be like, Joki actually doesn't care about the awards.
She's acting like you have one already.
I'm sick of this attitude, dude.
It's not my fault.
I know business.
I'm still going.
Where are you doing?
I'm making a peace offering.
Oh, okay.
Okay, sounds good.
We're waiting.
You're waiting?
You have to wait like a minute and a half.
I'm drawing.
You're taking a really long time.
There's dead air.
Do you not care about stream content?
Do you not care about us?
I'm trying.
Are you sabotaging?
Are you sabotaging our streams?
What's your favorite color?
That's the content.
We're here.
Do a flip, Philly.
Yeah, Philly.
Do a flip.
I'm drawing, dude!
What flip are you drawing?
I'm drawing a scene called Mask 2, okay?
Can you balance a plate on your head too?
Yes, watch.
What is this, like this?
Here?
Where did you grab a plate?
It wasn't glass.
We didn't hear it shatter.
It was a shell.
I feel like I was stolen from.
Robbed.
Skamaged.
Alright, Pippa.
I'm not very satisfied with this.
What do we do?
What do we want to talk about?
What should we talk about?
How much of a loser Philly is?
You know, I think Philly is just really bad at board games.
I think so too.
I think, you know, like the V-Fuber award is like the only sense of control she can have in her life.
That's why it's great.
Wow!
I think the saddest part is that she organized this collab and she got knocked out first.
That is pretty sad.
You know, like if you told me she threw for content, I wouldn't believe you.
Guys, if you guys want to watch winners...
No, no, no.
I have an offering.
Alright, check Discord.
Yeah?
There.
What is she...
The fuck is that?
What the fuck is that?
That's a house?
That's my last property.
Olive blabsh.
Olive blabsh?
I know the type word.
But it's my last property.
And I just want to say, Doki, you deserve it.
Okay.
I grew up in this area.
It was my five nights at Freddy's.
But I bestowed it to you.
This is the bit?
This is what you made us wait for?
This is it?
No.
I feel like I should get paid to even see this.
I feel like you should pay me to even look at this.
Time is money, Thelaine.
I can get mildly offended.
This is my business venture.
If you guys put in $5,000 each, I'll give you 1% company, okay?
To be fair...
And we've been... This is our exit plan from streaming, man.
Like five years.
We're old.
And no one gives a fuck anymore.
What are we gonna have?
I rather like...
This is your Amaranth gas station?
Oh, Brampt.
Okay.
To be fair, like after what we saw, how we saw you conduct business, I don't think I want to invest in anything that you offer.
How about you... Okay.
Okay.
Then show my stock, nerd.
Show my stock, nerd.
See what happens.
On the effing GameStop of the effing game chat.
I just don't like the stock, Thelaine.
I don't know what to say.
I just don't want to go.
Then short me.
I just don't like the stock.
You're no GameStop.
I'm sorry, Thelaine.
I don't think they'll let you... I don't think they'll allow you to be on the stock market because how...
We need more than like three steps to go on the stock market.
And FaZe is not being that, but I am.
I don't think you're allowed to be on the stock market.
It's getting...
I don't think so.
Okay.
Here's my plan.
I walk in with a Glock, right?
And I say it's fake.
Alright, hey guys.
Alright.
That was a great stream.
Yeah.
I had a great time with everyone playing.
And everybody... I had a great time winning Monopoly, guys.
I changed my mind.
I didn't have a great time.
I was here for a good time.
Ladies, ladies, you're all beautiful.
You're all beautiful women.
Wait, what was the word you just said?
We're all beautiful?
No, wait.
What Lumi said.
Ladies?
Ladies, nuts on your face.
Shut the fuck up, Fillion.
Okay.
Yes.
Fillion.
Fucking sore loser.
Okay.
GG's, everybody.
GG's.
Good collab, everyone.
GG.
It was a great time meeting you guys.
It was super fun.
It was a great time meeting you and me and Pippa.
Yeah, nice meeting you, Dokie.
And thanks, Fillion, for inviting me.
I love how toxic you are.
Thank you so much.
It's no problem.
Thank you for voting for us.
You invited me.
And thank you to Fillion for setting this collab up.
At this point, I think she's into this.
You know, like into the whole...
Yeah.
I think she's an M at that point, you know?
She's a huge M.
Why is it an M?
No, I'm an F.
She's clearly a huge M.
I'm an F.
Because she like, you know, she invited all three of us to like just rag on her.
And like, honestly, she's 100% an M at that point.
Don't hate toxic people.
I am an F.
You asked for this.
I am a woman.
Fillion, if you say oink oink, we'll give you the 5,000.
Oink?
Wait, what?
No, I'm waiting.
So...
At least she gets 2,500.
You get half of it.
Good job.
Yeah, I just got...
Give me 50%.
Idiot.
Can you do like a pig 3D model?
Let's play this again.
If you lose again, can we do like a 3D model?
Let's do this again.
If I lose, I'll make it a big maid outfit and then I'll wear it.
Yeah, but then you want that though.
You like that.
That doesn't...
You made it to be embarrassing.
We need it to be something you actually don't want to do.
Okay, then I don't want to be in a not in a maid outfit.
That's it.
So there.
I won't wear a maid outfit.
Hey.
You're a pig.
You guys.
GGs everybody.
GGs.
Whatever.
I'm going to talk to my chat now.
I had a great time.
Bye guys.
Bye.
Wow, that stream could have ended like an hour ago if I didn't prolong it for so long.
Guys sorry.
I know I have a second stream today but like I just did it.
I just wanted somebody to lose first.
Look, I just... I'm just saying, look, I know we could have ended... we could have like let them go from their misery.
But like I just wanted a specific person to lose first.
I did not expect to win Monopoly.
Not gonna lie.
I haven't played Monopoly in so long.
But like it's actually pretty funny when I can... I was like, you know, what was that word when you put your foot in the door where you negotiate for something much higher than what you actually want and they actually did that.
Did that and I was like guys that's basic business 101.
What the fu-
Um, but yeah, it was great.
I had a great time.
Um, I had a great time.
I guess like winning is always a good time.
So that's why I had-
I always have a good time winning, you know, it's always a blast.
Um, but Yeah, um, we do have a second stream.
We do have a second stream tonight with Fala.
I'm gonna, uh, I'm gonna push the stream, uh up by 15 minutes just so I can like chill a little bit because I didn't realize I'd play like three plus hours of Monopoly.
Also guys, I literally- Okay, it was so funny because like I told- I- I wouldn't be like I told you so because like I- I told them about like yeah, like there's like online issues with Monopoly because I know like people had to- in the past we would have- I remember like peop- like to go get around with it like someone would like screen share or something or like I don't remember- I don't think I've done remote play before but I don't- haven't played Monopoly but I remember like from recounts of others they would like screen share Monopoly and then like um,
and then like they'll like say what move they want to do and then that'll- they'll do them moves and stuff like that.
So like I knew there was that option and then there was like remote play.
So I was like guys, I think we gotta like don't use online feature because there's a huge online issue and I like brought that up like- like two to three- I think like three times and then- and then we went in I was like guys, I told- I told you guys.
I was like I told you guys there's online issues.
And I think the funniest part is that Fillion literally forgot the time that she set up.
Because I was like me, Pippa, and Lumi were watching the stream and then- and then like- like- like we saw her on like Bunny Girl and then we saw her like she was like why are they 30 minutes early like what the is going on like what's wrong with them and then I had to- I copied and pasted the exact time she told us to show up.
And it was like 2.30pm.
So me, Pippa, and Lumi were just sitting here waiting and being like guys what- what I thought?
Guys, are we supposed to start?
We were like are we supposed to start?
So we got confused too.
And we were like did we get the time right?
And then we just set up as like- As well.
Uhm.
Uh.
But yeah!
It was a fun time winning the game.
Anyway guys!
I'd love to talk more but we do have a second stream so I'll talk more in the second stream chat.
Uhm.
I'll see you guys there for a part 2 of Fallout 4!
Yeah!
Anyway guys, I am going to raid my own- my own channel.
I'll see you guys there everybody.
Bye guys!
Bye!